hello everybody hello hello it's another day for dokeybug um but yeah today we're gonna be doing a semi-long stream not too long because you know the week just started i don't want to fuck up my voice at the start of the week because we still have four more streams to do in the next couple days um but uh we're gonna do a semi-long maybe like four to five hours and then i want uh today today i want to do a little uh super chat oh my gosh finally we might be able to do super chat reading tonight i just want to chat with my dragoons for a little bit too post stream because you know i'm feeling a little quirky today um uh i wish in my voice and i'm ready to fuck it up all over again it's a cycle of pain anyway oh okay okay okay you guys didn't notice uh my youtube banner has finally updated after 20 years yeah i actually got a lot of these updated graphics a while ago um but i just i was just lazy and i didn't i don't know just just i guess like you know when you're updating graphics you
gotta update everything so like everything for your channel so because like i had these graphics done a while ago including the panels but i was like oh that requires me to update everything because if i'm gonna update the graphics i might as well just get everything done at once so i don't have to come back to it do it i'm gonna be productive so we have new panels on twitch and finally uh finally added all the emotes i forgot to add on twitch as well as uh the new youtube banner too so if you guys check youtube the new banner now um it's actually um oh what's the way like um you know i was going to remember elaine like i i was saving all my old graphics and stuff uh from my pre I guess,
like, pre-Corporeal era.
Because all those graphics were basically, like, yeah, I was going through memory lane, going through nostalgia, finally updating those graphics.
Because I had those graphics done, like, five-plus years ago.
That's how long it's been.
It's been there for five years.
Not even, maybe even longer than five years.
The original graphic designer.
Yeah, because it was RetroDoki.
The original graphic designer that did them.
She, like, when I became Corpo, she literally quit graphic design.
Like, she fucking disappeared off the internet to become a doctor.
That's, like, she literally disappeared.
The one, the person who did the original OG graphics.
Yeah, she, like, disappeared off the internet.
I've always loved her graphics, because I always, I wanted to, like, redo my stuff uh but she hasn't been active for like since i joined a company bro actually became a doctor yeah she's out there saving lives instead of making graphics for anime girls what what a glow up um um uh but yeah um i'm glad today i've been extra productive i needed that because I've been procrastinating a lot and just,
I've been zoning out and procrastinating a lot these days just because I've been, I feel, I don't want to say burnt out.
I've just been like, I guess overworked.
I've been feeling a bit overworked lately and by, it's not good that instead of like, you know, like it's not good that like to, my solution to recover from overwork is to stop working.
That's like, I don't know.
And then I came back to where I was like, wow, look at all the work that built up because I just stopped.
It's a cycle.
The cycle of pain continues.
I come back from not working just to see even more work.
How could this happen?
You mean if I stop working and more work, the work doesn't stop as well.
It just keeps piling on.
Who could have foresaw that?
Who would have known?
Who would have thought?
That's what happens.
If you don't do your work, the work itself doesn't just disappear and it just keeps coming in.
What a twist.
The world keeps spinning.
Who knew?
I thought I was the main gifter.
uh next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you guys thank you the super chat thank you thank you excuse me it's dr graphic designer for you thank you the super chat thank you thank you um but yeah so i today i was trying to be extra productive today like not only just updating my twitch and youtube but also um um getting all my um making sure like um making sure well i didn't answer all my my messages because i'll never be able to finish answering all my messages but you know just keeping up keeping keeping up to date with some things so yeah productive productive dokey today i might try to be productive after today's stream too might not just be like a three hour thing maybe maybe this entire week is going to be productive dokey whoa got subscribed to find out more if she does if she does become productive for this week.
Anyway, it is Doki Bug Time back into Silk Song.
So we have a little problem because today might be a filler episode because I realized during last stream, I did not gather any new charms or any new tools or basically anything.
I literally bashed my head against the wall until like I forced myself into the citadel.
uh
I was just like let me in And I threw my dead body against the wall like I don't know how many times Until a crack showed and I was like it can bleed and I slipped right in
After 50 dokiabug bodies I was finally led into the citadel um so we might have to backtrack today to grab some stuff because apparently the citadel is like actual hell um not only is it super capitalism but there's a lot of bad things there so i might i have i might have to backtrack but then i will require you guys to help me with backtracking because i don't know what to do all right also there's two saves because the other save i was
on how to play.
But I didn't want to get off the chair.
Because this is what happens when I get off the chair.
So so I um, so I put up a new save because I was like, how do I play this game again?
I didn't want to deal with super capitalism.
Um, alright.
uh gambit thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you thank you everybody for drawing a dokey bug all right i really i really appreciate it guys i have so much so many cute thumbnail the cute art to use for thumbnails the anti-poor benches it's only been you don't understand
I gotta figure out where to go, too.
Alright, we just gotta pogo this.
Oh, oh, I forgot I can float.
See, I told you I forgot, like, basic mechanics.
Alright, well, in order to be able to...
Oh, shit.
Alright, in order... Oh, shit.
Okay, it's fine.
In order to be able to grab anything, we gotta figure out how to get out of the Citadel.
Get out of here.
Go back to the slab and go left from the stag station.
Import.
Upgrade.
That way, don't worry.
You're supposed to be there.
Wait.
But like...
But like, why?
How?
Because like, I have nothing here.
But I have nothing.
Oh, no.
Now remember why I stopped playing last time.
Oh, Oh, no.
I remembered.
Wait, what's down here?
Is that... Is there anything down here, or is that death, guys?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I look down, and it's just the abyss.
It's just...
Oh, that's not so bad.
Okay, that's not so bad.
Okay, yeah, no, that was death.
Okay.
That's good to know.
This part I was like...
I was scared.
Also, I bought myself some London fog.
I needed some caffeine.
I didn't want to drink actual coffee.
So...
London fog...
London fog saved my life in university.
It's literally my...
It's my go-to...
It was my go-to study drink in university.
Oh, thank you for the rain!
Oh, I missed out the name, but thank you so much for the raid.
I appreciate it.
We had a good stream.
Oh, this is where I died.
I hesitated.
Oh, my God.
I hesitated again.
Oh, Tori, thank you for the...
No!
Alright.
Okay.
I got this.
there we go that's fine wait do i go is there anything over here is there anything okay oh shit all right that's fine who's over here is he a good guy nope nope he is not he guys it's crazy he was apparently not a good person oh my god okay we'll leave you win Please I'm I'm so low All right,
oh They do two damage.
Oh That's cool Please let me farm you Oh my god.
What am I looking at geometry?
What the fuck is this?
Okay
All right now I'm here Okay, you definitely don't look like a good person.
But you're my heal.
Alright, I killed the janitor.
I am a good person.
I did it, guys.
I killed the janitor.
Oh!
Okay, we're fine.
Where is this place?
I don't remember this place.
Oh, wait.
What was the other area here, right?
Alright.
Gotta kill him.
I feel like he has something good.
Maybe?
Okay.
There you go.
I assume he has that...
Oh, nice.
There's a little thing here.
Okay, that's not...
Not as nice as I thought.
What's this?
Oh, shard bundle.
I don't know.
He was very useless.
Oh, thank you, Ben.
Thank you.
That's right, it's me, Doki Bug.
All right.
Got to time this.
Oh, shit.
What's he doing here?
All right.
It's fine.
Oh, shit!
That's not fine.
Oh, my God.
Please, are there any?
Are all chairs paid a sit?
is that the society we live in now oh my god your stupid fucking body oh my I'm leaving he wins no poor please
capitalism reigns supreme here now I have to do this all over again I don't...
No!
I thought you were Conrad!
Okay.
Alright, we're just gonna skip all of that.
I thought you're Conrad!
I thought you fight against capitalism!
What happened?
Alright, let's see.
I don't trust myself.
I gotta dash through that.
Not comrade.
Seriously.
Oh, shit!
I looked at chat.
Was that obvious?
I looked at chat, guys.
Alright, here.
Okay.
It's fine.
we made it all right I'm just gonna heal just in case because I don't trust myself I don't care we missed the map my goal is to get out of here oh my god oh my god I uprooted accidentally I'm just that much of a gamer I uprooted out of his pure instinct are you serious are you serious there you go oh I'm just gonna heal
silly me oh I'm leaving oh my god please oh please oh my god there's more
oh there's so much more it's okay oh please leave me alone
are you serious oh god please tell me there's something here oh there it's not okay i mean that's technically something oh my god it's him it's him okay it's fine it's fine i dodged oh my god it's not fine it's here i go right side oh there's a chair there is a chair oh of course of course of course I thought I could I thought I was I was strong my legs were strong enough I thought my legs I thought my legs were strong enough we're thick enough okay bro it was just one jump I didn't realize I have weak-ass legs!
My tiny sick legs failed me yet again.
I didn't focus on my leg game.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot about that guy.
My noodle legs.
Now, okay, now grab the... No!
I don't know where the map still is.
I would grab the map If I knew where it is guys Unfortunately I do not know
There you go Oh I need the map to find the map Exactly
How could you expect me to find the map when I don't have the map to help me find that map.
Okay, let's go try and grab our chair first.
I mean, of course it's on the other side.
Because nothing is fair in life.
Alright.
Okay.
I assume the chair is above me.
Oh, look at all these paedicit benches.
Wow.
What?
at a time please super capitalism one at a time so many many chairs to pay for what a steal oh my god it only 15.99 wow my god i wish they had five more of these chairs too all right let's see
They become pay to pay.
Oh, hey, there is a secret.
What is this?
Insert rosaries.
What does this do?
Speak now.
The confession will be heard.
You have confessed to sin.
Most grave.
You are forgiven.
Look at that.
See, guys?
I ain't going to hell.
That's all I have.
I just got to go.
gotta pay and then god will forgive me i just gotta be a tier one sub to god doesn't matter how much murder i've committed as jokey bug as long as i'm a tier one sub to god and on the donor leader boards i'm let in pay to pay to heaven amen you have confessed to sin must by work cleanse yourself return to your task and work off cycle neither eating nor stopping until new cycle begins by the grace of our loon eternal may you never tire toil and be forgiven you oh my god isn't that great i have been forgiven guys remember to donate so your sins can be forgiven guys just like the good old days oh my jesus christ for 25.99 a month rosaries a month you too can have your sins exactly jesus you know what up from the man himself thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh memory lock oh he needed that all right let's go down oh my god i can't even unlock my memory lock i'm too poor i'm too poor
okay jesus has returned hallelujah He supports super capitalism.
Where am I?
Like, where?
Alright, there you go.
Hallelujah.
Jesus was in fact a blue collar worker all along.
And when you open that.
Wait, is blue collar...
Okay, is blue collar the one with...
the office jobs or is that white collar sorry jesus was a white collar worker all along i mean he was a carpenter
yeah jesus was the son of a carpenter and he uh and he and he helped his dad wait his stepdad uh technically his stepdad uh what is this also chair wait that's a permanent chair
okay what is this open oh down here oh shit okay now that i know and i've learned my lesson oh my god i have learned my lesson he helped us set that step dad turn the simple carpeting job wait why does it stop here in the conglomerate Forbes multi-million dollar company it is today.
And it's called...
It's called Greciatic.
Thank you, Jesus.
Alright.
Okay, I should not have used that.
Oh, okay.
I really don't like these blasts.
This is...
Don't worry, it doesn't count as blasts!
All I have to do is go back and confess my sins, and then I shall be forgiven.
Oh my god.
Fucking hell, I hate these big boys.
Oh my god, fuck up, leave.
Nope, oh my god, and there's...
There's...
Thank god when I...
Don't worry, guys.
For doing...
For making that...
Oh, I don't have money.
I have yet to be forgiven.
When he was risen, it was the first case of...
pulling yourself by your bootstrap actually working out.
Thank you for the chip chat, banana.
Thank you.
They never expect a second one.
That's why I was like that's why I played with my life there.
I was like, I won.
We can make it as close as it can get.
I thought I won.
Can I just skip that?
Yeah, I can.
Wait, this place is hell.
Now that I think about it.
Wait, how did I...
Oh, it was down here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That was close.
I think it was here?
No, it was here.
Alright, we gotta kill these guys again.
Okay.
As long as he doesn't do that thing, we're...
Okay, that...
Oh, that's fine.
I was really far away.
There you go.
Okay, I hate these guys, so I'm just gonna use the magic just for him.
That's how much I hate you.
That's how much of a... of a hater I am.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Alright.
Whoa!
What?!
Okay.
Jesus.
There you go.
That's the second boy.
The second big boy.
Are you serious?
He just needed to...
Oh my...
Oh, there's more!
Oh, my.
Oh, shit.
Please don't touch me.
This sucks.
This actually sucks.
Okay.
Nice.
I can't believe I died to a scripted event.
What's this?
Oh, it's the silk spool.
They just have more money.
Where am I?
Guys, if only I have a map.
Oh, man.
I wish to say if only there was a map this game it's so unfortunate have i got this place yet oh i haven't that i don't care i hate these guys so much oh my god i hate these guys so much
man a map would be really nice by now if only exists in this game
It's a crazy concept.
Too bad Silk Stop never added a map, guys.
Oh, that's true.
I do have my spike tool.
Please, please.
I can't float forever.
No!
I hate this.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Get him out of here.
Get him out of my lobby.
Is there anything up here?
Okay, that seems like a boss, but I'm not going there yet.
I'll just rob some money before I die.
Okay.
Oh, my...
That's it.
Oh, that doesn't matter.
Oh!
Stupid fucking flyer!
Oh, I hate these guys.
I parried so much still.
I did so many parries, but it never doesn't matter.
It never...
Oh, shit!
It never matters.
Okay, it's back here.
Oh, fine.
Okay, that's on me.
That's on What's a plan there?
I don't know.
I don't know There was no plan.
There never has been a plan.
Oh my god, not another one.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
There you go.
You'll anti-air them, surely.
I focused too much on anti-air.
I was like, you know what?
I got this.
I have a tool.
In the end, I actually don't...
I'm not paying to sit on that bench again.
I don't even have money.
Okay.
I don't know what was in my mind when I did that.
This place sucks.
That's all that's in my mind.
This place is hell.
Oh my god, that was so close.
Alright.
Lock in.
I didn't know he could jump.
I didn't.
Okay.
Alright.
Another big boy.
Okay.
As long as I kill him, I can heal.
Are you serious?
I hit his head!
Okay, that's fine.
I'm locked in for real.
Don't worry, I got my London fog in my system.
Okay.
Come on, spit your thing out.
Come on.
I hate you.
I hope I hope you don't come back alive to see your parents Oh god Are you serious that doesn't Unlock you Oh my god Why would you go backwards?
Why would you go backwards?
Oh my god You should I'm not okay anymore I'm not okay it's fine if I die I'm literally broke right now super capitalism has done its work I have no money
it has done its job I can't even afford to live here I can't even afford to live here
all right all right
Are you secret?
No!
That's stupid fucking...
That's it.
I need a...
Oh, I can't even change it.
I can't even change it because I got off the goddamn chair!
It's fine.
It works, guys.
Don't you know it?
Okay, I'm focused.
I'm struggling so much because of Liar and Big Boy.
That double combo.
Okay, I got this.
I got this just...
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Oh my god, what are you doing?
Did anyone get his license late?
See, that's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
Everything has gone according the plan.
That's good.
I actually needed the extra magic here.
Alright.
Is there a secret?
Why was she there?
Oh, she was just a gen.
Don't cute.
What do you mean why was she there?
She was trying to do her job.
Cleaning!
Oh wait, where does this go?
What?
There's nothing here.
I don't even know where to go.
Wow, if only this game had a map, it's crazy that they did.
It's actually crazy that they didn't add a map in this game, guys.
Can't believe it.
What the fuck is this?
It's a ghost spider.
Oh my god, a fucking course.
There was something over there.
Oh.
Okay.
Where the fuck am I?
Let's all go this way.
Wait.
Can I...
Oh.
Okay, I can.
What is this place?
Am I even supposed to be here?
Oh my god, I didn't see him.
Ghost bat.
Oh!
Of course.
Of course there's a hidden...
Hidden...
What are they called?
Spinning wheels of death.
Oh my god, a free chair.
Is this a lie?
Are there any traps?
I don't believe it.
it there's a free chair nothing comes for free through everything comes with a price i don't believe it a free chair all right how do i use two at the same time oh down rb
okay hita thank you for the super chat thingy thank you uh from here you go left to leave the city.
I'll go to a bell station and head to the slab.
Then go forward left to the cult.
You need that upgrade.
Okay.
Okay, but what about charms?
I feel like I lack a lot of charm upgrade and stuff.
And tools too.
I literally have only one charm and it's the magma shit.
That doesn't seem right.
I feel like I need more.
Oh hey, money.
I feel like this game doesn't have one charm.
All right, we go left.
Just like how this game has no map.
There you go.
We go here.
Oh my god, that's scary.
I just decided to float at the last second.
I was like, hmm.
Maybe I should start floating.
Well, I'd die if I flow all the way down.
I assume not, right?
Okay.
I assume this is how to get out.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, and this is a pilgrimage place.
Oh, it's a safe area.
Okay, nice.
Alright, now I can leave.
Where is the bell station?
Wait, did I?
Did I miss the bell station?
Where the fuck is the bell station here?
If only I have a map to tell me where it is.
Oh, I do.
Left?
Oh.
Oh, I have to go all the way back.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Where am I?
Oh, yeah, I took that off.
I was like, where am I?
How do I get home?
It's all the way over there.
I'll just keep going, though.
For five.
Alright, here it is.
I think it's here.
Yeah.
Okay, let's grab... I forgot I don't have my compass.
Let's grab that.
Oh.
Alright, where do we go?
Then go full left to the cold station.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I realized I forgot to do something.
So apparently it's like tomorrow.
Battle tomorrow.
And then we gotta go back Where's the prison area?
Oh, we can just do this.
Alright, so.
We forgot to free some people in their jail.
Oh, so.
We gotta go do that real quick.
So we gotta save some people in jail because I forgot about them.
Because I thought, like, I thought, you know, I need a key because they're in jail.
But apparently you can just break the jail cell and I'm like, what's the point of locking them up if it's just that easy to free them?
And clearly their crime was not that bad if the security is that weak.
It's like this way?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, who's who's stronger one one little pilgrim or or the judge?
the last the last bodyguard of the citadel all right let's see is this way
is here yeah all right oh what the fuck wait was it there you no where's the jail that's i forgot who you are who are you oh yeah welcome so glad you found i can see you're blessed with strong glimpse and keen insight fond of the frolics are you keen to test your aim we'd be right honored to play a little game with you a little test of skill if you set up i have no need to test my skill sir nor do i have time for frivolities oh but we made it worth your while a prize awaits you we can meet our challenge if you offer a prize that changes matt that that changes matters i can meet any challenge What are the rules for your game?
Hex is ceiling simple, my lady.
I'll provide the pins for throwing.
And my associates will provide a target.
Hit the target 15 times and you'll earn yourself a worthy prize.
I have to pay for it.
What is this fucking carnival game?
Okay.
I thought this was a jail.
Where are the criminals?
Oh, he's still there.
Oh, wait.
Oh, they're freed.
I did it guys.
I freed him.
Okay, this is what I was saying that it was a jail I did it guys.
I did it He got he freed himself Anyway, um Okay, so I didn't realize you can break this because I was like it's it's locked up Like, you know, oh wait, this guy died because it took too long.
His body became backborn with nature.
That's how...
Okay, let's try this out.
Fuck it.
Alright.
Time to play.
Take these straight pins and you can strike the target 15 times.
How do I play this?
What?
Oh.
what what the fuck oh my god this is a carnival this is a carnival game all right let's try this again that's fine i'm already broke anyway guys you don't understand i gotta win that bootleg la foo foo plus you don't understand i have to win the la foo foo bootleg plus there you go no okay oh oh stupid oh my god when he does the no i gotta keep going oh my god i'm broke no not you too it's okay oh i can't even farm it anything.
There's no pilgrims here.
It's not okay.
There's no pilgrims.
Where do I go now?
I only came back to save that one guy.
Oh, wait.
There is.
Wait, there is.
Wait, do you come back?
It's okay.
I know there's more.
Please.
I have to play that game.
Okay.
Where is another pilgrim i know they're still there i know there's still some pilgrims to rob when are you serious like the slowest fucking friend of my all time
oh my god where are the other pilgrims i hate this i hate this guy i'm going back to the bench fuck this
i'm resetting beating up beating up the to fund my gambling addiction.
It's okay.
I can confess later.
Wait, do I have enough?
I have...
It's fine.
This is why I keep those rosaries.
Alright.
I'll spend $100 to win a $5 prize.
Okay.
all right nice five my time for this okay oh no there you go 12 13 okay no 14 no it was a win Oh my god, there was no dice fight.
Oh, I still have one more I have one more I want song okay, yeah, okay.
I can't tell a story yet.
I He threw me off he would
The patterns different Okay All right Are you serious?
No!
I didn't mean to press it!
I didn't!
It's okay.
I have more.
Okay.
He has to get.
Oh my god.
What do you mean there's RNG in my carnival game?
Are you trying to tell me that?
No!
That it's ring?
No way.
They're just trying to make an honest living
Okay I still have more I still have more money That was so I could do this Alright Oh
He ducked the bug ducks you don't understand he crushed down he crushed down it was rigged
He stopped guys.
Did you not see it?
Okay, I just need...
It read my input chat.
It's okay.
I got...
Okay, so like, one time I was at a carnival, and there was like those shooting games where you get...
It's like a rifle with a cork at the end, and you just got hit the target, knocked down like three targets to win a one prize like and the prize is a big ass and then there was this guy and he was surrounded by like three other girls and like you know like another bro and he's like yeah like you could tell that he had like some form like maybe like military training or some shit because when he was like shooting the when he was trying to shoot the gun it was like because like i live in canada so it's like weird that you know like it's harder to actually have like have experience holding a gun so there was this guy and then the thing is you know they're super fucking rigged and everything so like maybe like the the the the iron sight isn't um the iron sight isn't like accurate or anything on the gun itself so he looked like he was a natural with it like with how he was holding the rifle and like positioning wise and everything and he was like and and so like the first i was watching him
because I was curious because I was like, oh, it looks fun.
Like maybe my, does my FPS skill translate to this?
So I wanted to give it a shot.
And so I was waiting there.
And then he couldn't hit any target.
He didn't hit, he only hit one target after, like, because you get five shots and he only hit one.
So then he's like, okay, I'm going to try again because, you know, all the girls were around him and he was like, I got to show off.
And so like, I was like, all right.
And then like, and then he kept missing.
it but he was at that point it was over he was determined like he was like so he had like an ego to prove at that point so i was like okay this guy this guy's gonna take a while uh i was like bros yeah bros gotta risk like like you know all the ladies were watching him and he's like i gotta i gotta prove myself at that point he didn't want to embarrass himself so so i was Like,
okay, I'll just come back, because I feel like he's going to be here for a while.
And then, so I left, literally for 30 minutes, and then I came back, because I really wanted to try this carnival game.
And then he was still there, but he took off his jacket, because you know he was serious now.
But he did win one time, because one of the girls was carrying a giant ass stuffed toy now.
So then, but I think he wanted, but he didn't want it to win for all the girls.
and so like so like I was watching again because I was like surely like he'll like be done with this right so then I watched a little bit and you know he would hit the shots but then he'll miss like one target and so I was like okay I'll come back again I'll wait another hour and so like I came back another hour the girls now have three giant plushies but he was still there he was still he paying this carnival game more money I don't even know what the point was anymore I was like all the girls got their big ass plushie why it's still here it was trying to fight it was personal now bro had a mission it's about the message it's a good thing Kat that doesn't get into wars that main thing it was for the love of the game so that was like so i was like okay i'll come back when it's closing time so maybe by then he'll be god and then literally i came back and that guy was still trying to shoot targets i don't understand how all like him and his friend group were like like his friend group
were just okay with that like it was like he was there for two and a half hours i swear and then finally i just waited because i was like okay it's 30 minutes till closing time surely he'll leave and then eventually he actually finally left and i was just like oh my god i was like this man because it was like i think it was like 15 it was 15 per play i swear to god that carnival game farmed like 500 off of this man like at least five hundred dollars off of him like because i bet you in his head he's like he's like he's like um i went to military for this why can't i hit the target i even went to military school what's the point of joining the army if i can't hit this stupid ass paper target what the carnies were big he's like i went to war but yet i can't even hit this toddy at that stupid ass paper target with a fucking corkscrew gun like he must be military we're stupid with money like thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
Alright, time to do this again.
Warwin the favorite target.
Alright.
Slow and steady.
Ah!
I feel like I'm getting worse.
Oh my god.
I am definitely getting worse.
Okay.
Oh, that was scary.
Alright.
Okay.
No!
I pressed it too soon!
Oh!
No, I'm extra broke now!
I pressed it too soon!
I...
Yeah, he graduated top of his class and he's gonna prove it.
I can't believe it.
dropped it's so sick now it's my turn to spend $500 guys can anyone spot me five grand like that's how I think I'm gonna be here because they want to spot me I swear at I owe you for this carnival game he's nailed that cat is there like I don't even remember all the pilgrims live this is the whole stream now
all right it's
fine we got this
okay i gotta make sure like her body doesn't die on on the spike so i can still rob her All right, we're almost there.
Please win us a bootleg Lafoo.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
I got you, bro.
Guys, guys, please, I owe you.
I gotta win us the giant ass Lafoo-foo doll, guys.
Look, I might have spent $500.
And the Lafoufou cost $5 on Timu, but you don't understand.
The Boolet, the Lafoufou on Timu doesn't have the same...
The same aura as winning it from a carnival game.
You don't understand.
It's about the experience.
You have a memory from it.
We tell that story.
All right, I have enough.
It's a story.
It's a momento.
All right, I got this.
All right.
Low and steady.
Okay.
wait all right nice are you serious okay that's fine okay I have to remember if that one was the okay I did it there we go look at that I got you you're the foo-foo only took me 500 but i did it i did it guys i got us a souvenir oh yeah oh la that's it then our lady has struck the target 15 times a beautiful victory hopefully you enjoyed yourself a little levity is a bomb in these troubled times don't you think i thought about such game the game's best say for times of peace perhaps there's truth in what you say and now i've bested your challenge you will produce Oh,
of course.
I see you have a tool pouch of your own there.
Bold, bursting with bubbles and trinkets, no doubt.
I'll fit another pocket onto it so you can carry even more tools and shards with you.
A fair prize, wouldn't you say?
Oh, nice.
I got my tool pouch expanded.
We can play Hit the Target and you'll earn yourself a beautiful necklace of rosaries.
Oh, my God.
I can do that.
All right, guys, give me a sec.
Guys, guys, can you...
Can I owe you $25?
Wait, it's more?
Oh, wait, no, it was always $25.
I was going to say.
That's good.
It's not over yet.
No, it's over.
They're just giving me money.
Like, I feel like the net is not going to be a net positive.
I feel like I might spend more than I make from it.
Just a theory.
all right nice i gotta grab some silk too on the way uh all right let's grab the chair over here
towards the carnival game can't sleep it so i'm here to listen to stories hope you're all having a good day thank you for the super chat guys thank you thank you what the fuck is dead lock spell where's that
it steps I was in the wait where was that was I in the okay I was in the underworks what the fuck is dead locks bell bottom oh deep docks I don't know why I said dead lock I've been watching I've been watching I was watching a dead lock stream today I swear does dead looks look uglier like did they did they make the game uglier i swear it's so like i feel like there's like actual no shaders or lighting applied to the game for the newest update but everyone's saying it's like a lot better now but i swear to god it looked like it it looked a little it looked like uglier than what i feel like i'm not sure if it's because all the streamers turned their graphics to low but but like there's like i feel like it's just there's no shade like the the map for deadlock had less color i was so surprised like how could it have less color like i think i think i think like all the streamers i was watching for deadlock was playing on the lowest graphics possible because because there was actually it
felt like there was like it was and brown in an entire map.
Uh, okay.
Uh, so you get to the room that will jump top, right, in room to slab?
What?
This?
Oh, you mean this.
This area.
Oh, you want me to go here!
Okay.
Right?
Is that what you want me to go to?
Here?
There's no Hold on, or is it here?
Oh, here!
Okay.
What is up there?
Alright, where am I?
I'll just bell it.
Alright.
Ducks.
Matio, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
An optional cell version of an area?
Wait.
Is that version supposed to be easier or not easy?
Because if they're trying to trick me into going to a harder part, doing a harder version.
I know lucky.
No, it's so much harder.
Okay, chat's fighting again.
Some people say it's harder and others are saying it's easier.
Wait, why stealth?
I hate stealth.
Why are you making me do stealth?
Oh my god, I'm getting beat up by a child right now because I'm looking at chat.
It's funnier?
How much funnier, though?
Alright.
Very funny.
Okay.
Alright.
For reasons of funny, I'll head over.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, we'll go there.
Alright, let's heal up for there.
Yeah?
Wait, why does he have a cage?
Okay.
Oh.
Is he trying to kidnap me?
Wait a minute.
Wait, there's a person in there.
All right, give me a sec.
I gotta grab some silk real quick.
I'm not here to get caged.
I've avoided authorities long enough.
I ain't going back
He just wants to sell me What does this sell me something?
I think he's gonna sell me I ain't going back They can't get me I avoided the authorities lying enough They won't get me for my crimes I've confessed They said it They said if I confess I get to be free
I confess for my crimes They said if I confess That everything would be forgiven Oh my god No Let me out Let me out Time Time I have to do my time now Time Caged for my crimes.
Wait, am I naked?
Oh my god!
It's super jail!
They actually dug my clothes!
Oh my god, I'm in super jail!
I have
clothes!
Oh my god, I gotta put some meat on my bones.
I'm so skinny, no wonder.
Can I still jump?
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh my god, I got my legs, though.
Ha, ha.
Go off with the Mark Heretic.
This is now an 18th place.
I heard that you can mod your...
Oh my god, I can't fly.
I forgot I can't fly.
They actually took my robes, too.
I heard that they made a mod where you can be naked the entire time.
It was like literally one of the first mods they made.
Other than taking away the minus 2 damage, being naked was the very first mod they've ever made for this game.
Where do I go?
I'm just naked.
I'm naked and free.
It's time to do my time.
Time to pay for the crimes I've committed.
What?
Where do I go?
Let
me in!
Let me in!
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is the super curvy.
Curvy so soft from all the fan art.
Room below ceiling.
Down, left, up.
What breaks?
I'm fucking... I'm kicking all the walls.
I did?
this room oh there i see it upper kick all right oh shit all right up i'll go
oh my god he has my clothes he has my clothes they got it they got it in the in the robe raid give me my clothes back god damn perfect Oh.
Okay, how strong are my kicks though?
Okay, never a mile, never, I can never tell.
It's like, it's like a pantheon raid, but for my robes.
Okay, there must be a way to get up there.
Oh, I'm so cold, I'm so cold!
Oh no, I'm so cold!
Wait, can I like parry?
Oh my god, I can't parry that.
I can't imagine I parry it with my feet
Can I go here?
I'm so good.
I'm so good
Where am I?
Hello?
You're looking a little stuck here.
What a pity.
We meet again, little thief.
Are you familiar with this place?
If we ally our efforts, our escape could be made that much easier.
Oh, you just think?
There are no allies in prison.
You can just throw yourself against the wall in there while I go sniffing for goodies.
Oh, my God, you asshole.
Just because I freed you.
What's this?
Please, oh my god, I can't, I'm so weak, my legs, I didn't do leg day.
It's not fair, I skipped leg day.
Eh.
I mean, do I even have money down there?
I feel like I was like extra broke.
I never skipped leg day.
day.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh my god.
Okay.
E of Indolent.
Where is Indolent?
Is it this?
Oh yeah, there it is.
Nice.
My skinny ass leg doesn't do enough damage where
is oh my god they took my map too they took everything from me wait what what is this called okay oh i have indolent
she's letting oh yeah guys i i saw on my poor you page that uh jane silk son bucks
Okay, I don't know if I'm supposed to...
Oh, shit.
Unlucky.
Can I heal from this?
Oh, you can.
It's true.
Oh, it's this place again.
Oh, it's this place.
What the fuck?
Where am I supposed to go?
There's nothing here.
Oh.
All right.
Am I supposed to go right?
No, okay.
Uh?
Wait, do I have all the keys needed?
I don't have the heretic key though.
Or maybe to the right side.
Okay.
I gotta find another key.
I don't know about how many keys I...
Is this key where?
Apostate.
Wasn't that a...
This was Heretic, right?
Okay, I don't have Heretic.
What other doors are there?
Hello?
Oh wait, this is new?
Oh, I didn't realize there's a...
Oh wait, this is where I came from.
Okay.
There's a chair here.
Oh, there you are.
That's right, I'm gonna kick your ass.
Get over here.
At least give me clothes.
Why, we thought one of them buzzing bullies was sneaking up on us, but it's just a mangy gel bug.
Why are you in here, then?
Caught feeding, were you?
Creedy, greedy.
Magina for a.
I've stolen nothing.
Rather, I suspect the warden and their servants of the Citadel.
The cage used in my capture bore similar runes to the one that first brought me to this land.
Beyond, found in that cage, I've proven fine gift where they do deliver me to their master.
there ain't nothing fine about excuse me look at this body are you what are you serious no taste
we recognize a fellow thief soon as we saw you dude is blind as hell now don't be lingering around here those guys be one to pop you back into your cage quick quick wineda do not get a chance i will clean my blinds and leave this grim place with paste i bet you i bet you this bug okay i shouldn't say it i oh what the fuck oh my god it's like jailbreak it's like prison break guys he has the map tattoo on his fucking body gotta take the map how am i taking oh my god i was like how the fuck am i gonna take this map it's literally i was like okay that works okay yep just have a piece of body part on my on me all right all right i bet you i bet you the reason why he doesn't think he doesn't he doesn't think i look fine as hell it's because he
He is a BBB enjoyer.
Big beautiful bug.
He likes them extra thick.
Alright,
let's see.
Alright, side.
I can tell.
I know he's a BBB enjoyer.
Or he's fucking.
blood.
There's no way!
Look at me!
What?
Someone chanting here.
There's nobody here.
Hello?
Knock knock.
Motomokto bug like it.
He likes some big.
He likes Get some chunky, chunky.
Oh, what?
Okay.
Oh, I have... What?
Okay, I have to use this to my advantage.
There we go.
This is...
This is dumb.
You see?
serious?
Oh my god, are you serious?
Come at.
Oh my god, I forgot where it went.
There you go.
Oh, I forgot this goes, okay, this is left, this one's right.
Alright, this is right, this is left.
Where's the last one?
God damn it.
I have to use this then.
There you go.
Oh, this is so...
Are you serious?
I can't even Dodge it?
Ah!
Woo!
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please go over here.
Okay, there.
Alright.
Gotta go this way.
Gotta jump this way.
Oh, I can't parkour that.
Wait, how do I...
what the oh my god are you serious i i'm thinking i can't just kick the spikes guys all right this way is there anything here no that's just bait my legs they're not made of steel
oh my god okay
i do know that guys because look at how thin as my six legs are Nigs!
I ain't parrying anything!
I got to worry myself up.
Serious?
You won't know until you try.
Okay, at least I can do that.
That's good.
Yeah, unlock this first before I go down.
Oh my god, there's a chair down here.
As I go down from here.
Oh, wait.
There he is.
Oh, gross.
You guys...
There he has grime all over my rope.
Oh, he's stretching it.
That is a...
That is a Louis Vuitton original, and he's stretching it.
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
I'm angry.
Oh, my God.
How do I...
Okay, I'm angry.
Oh!
oh my god i was very oh my god i was angry i told you i told you i was angry i i did not when i said i was angry i
ain't holding back
oh oh shit ew that's oh wait that doesn't do a damage though at least it doesn't do any damage that's good When do we get that move?
When can I break their necks?
It seems pretty OP.
Why can't I do that?
Yeah, I gotta watch this.
I don't know where he's been.
It doesn't even look like he's showered in a while, too.
It's fine.
It doesn't do any damage.
There we go.
Oh, nice.
I got the key of Herodic.
That's what we need it.
Oh, nice chair.
Okay, now.
Now where the fuck am I?
What the slag?
Yeah, use it.
Wait, I can read a description of my cloak.
What happened to it?
How?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, here.
Oh, no.
Ah, he got fly all over my cloak.
gross oh shit all my Chris got reset too they took away my Chris too ah you know okay you know like when flies do the rubbing together thing you see this the flies do the rubbing their hands together they actually like vomit on their hands while they're rubbing it that's what they're doing when they're eating they actually like vomit out they vomit and then like put it back in their face.
I don't know why they do it.
I just, that's all I remember.
I don't know exactly why they have to do that to fucking eat, but, but they always, they like, they like vomit into their hands, and that's why they're always rubbing it.
I don't know fucking, oh, it's to digest it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah.
It's to digest it.
It's to digest the food better, to soften it up.
So, I technically have bug vomit on my robe now.
And that is That is why I snapped his neck.
That is why I was justified to snap his neck.
Was I using Wunderer?
Wait, what was the...
Oh, it's Reaper.
Oh, my God.
They reset the Reaper as well.
Reset everything.
Okay.
Adidas.
Alright, I need compass, this, magma.
The more you know.
Alright.
Now where do I go?
Okay, now there's no way I can be that cold now.
I have the heretic thing.
Can I unlock anything?
Maybe all the way down?
Oh yeah, so technically they're spitting their stomach acid into me right now.
They're actually projectile vomiting at me.
Okay.
Oh, technically, yeah.
I'll feed him up just for the money.
I need the money.
Wait, I hear him.
Oh, he's in here.
I hear the little dog fly.
The dog flea.
Okay, downtime.
Oh, is this heretic?
Oh, I got heretic.
Yay!
I'm a heretic.
Uh, open sesame.
Guess I'll go left.
Oh, wait, nice.
There's a bell station.
Alright, let's go to that bell station.
So this way.
Hello, little baby.
Goodbye, little baby.
Where's the bell station?
What the fuck were you doing with that big boy?
Huh?
What were you doing?
Interacting with that prisoner there?
Colluding with the prisoner?
Oh my, I told you.
I told you.
These flies down there.
They're BBB and joyers.
I told you.
you.
Oh, oh, oh, that still does damage to me?
Having a little private time there.
Okay, the bell is here.
Do I have money?
God damn, I don't.
I like $40.
Let them freak Doki.
Don't kick shame them let them be free oh my god look at this oh my god i it's like a girl in closet watch
or it watches in closet
Bugs!
Give me your money.
Oh, they don't even have money because they don't get paid in cash.
They get paid in giant ass bugs.
Rude!
Alright.
I need like $40.
I forgot how slow the Reaper is though.
Are you running?
There we go.
Oh my god, more shard bundles.
It feels useless.
Did I have...
Oh, shit.
Let's try to see if I have 40 yet.
How much do I have?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Wait, is it 40 or 80?
I was technically not reading.
No, I'll use my tools.
Oh, fuck, that wasn't a tool.
I'm gonna do it.
Freaky-ass bugs.
It was 40.
Okay, good.
Because I wasn't actually reading.
Alright.
Yay!
Come in, come in!
Come in, boy!
Oh, wait.
He doesn't show up yet.
I should go to the chair first and get full HP.
I almost forgot about the chair.
Okay, go left.
Surely now that I have my clothes, I won't freeze, right?
Oh, no, I'm still freezing.
I have!
Oh, it's because I didn't put my pants on.
It's because...
It's because Jane Silk Song isn't wearing pants.
God damn it.
What do I do?
I'm so good.
Oh my god, I might die!
Oh my god, I'm gonna freeze!
That's it, Keita.
You lost your backseeing privilege.
You let me freeze to death.
How did you forget that I have no pants on?
All right.
Nominate a new backseater for me.
It's time.
Elect a new backseater.
The council elect a new backseater.
Thank you.
I think it was super chat.
All right, where do we go?
There's cool stuff in the first area?
You mean, da moro?
All right, where do we go now, guys?
We're still doing the filler episode.
Deep dock, so you have... I don't have a key.
I have no key.
Alright, guys.
Now I'm lost.
Are I done any?
Wait, where am I, actually?
Oh, wait.
It's bone bottom, not tomorrow.
Back to the hunters' march for a very useful item.
Where's the useful item?
I should get rid of these.
I don't need to use...
you'll need these anymore i didn't do wishes oh my god how many make a wish kids are there in this bug world all right oh i don't have wishes here where wishes do i have oh berry picking oh i gotta get to go to the druid oh my gosh so many people i i hope they all they're all alive still i hope all these make a wish kids are still um okay the druid all right oh you've done none of them don't worry those kids are still alive they gone through remission it's fine i believe in those kids wait where is where does the druid live i don't remember oh here right where did that druid live like yeah oh there she is
You're my thanks for seeing them up.
Wait, where does she live?
Do I have...
Wait, how do I play music again?
Oh, this is...
Okay.
Go down right to a scary door and play something cool.
Down right.
Oh, this way.
I'm sorry, they all look like evil witches.
Like, did you not see your hunchback?
She looked so... She looked like a witch.
Made me want to burn her.
You want to be like, burn the witch.
Wait, how many...
Wait.
Alright.
This way.
This is the door.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
Hello.
The Atlas.
What's wrong with this guy?
Why is he just looking at me like that?
That's the worst security of- wait, what?
The worst security system they have.
Anyone here?
Oh, it's like...
Oh, it's a puzzle!
I did it!
I completed a puzzle!
Oh my god, guys, I'm so smart.
I completed the hardest puzzle in this game.
I ruined depicting the weave nest.
Yeah, I'll take the map.
What a hard puzzle.
Oh, there's something below.
Oh, I start...
on the power.
It's on the right.
Okay, gotta hit down.
Hello, anybody here?
Hello?
Who's there?
Has someone come to free me?
Or are you here to bring my end?
I am hornet, prisoner.
Only a traveler are not here to slay you.
What cause sees you cage in these ruins of Weaver's past?
were you their enemy no not their enemy and the prisoner not through malice i am eva a thing difficult to describe the child of weavers yet not quite their kin how strange that description could fit me as yourself could fit me as well as yourself child of weavers and not i can detect your weaver strain yet you're different from them and from me of shifting blending thing what are you creature um i am a demigod my father is a god too so you better respect me you're not going into a bug heaven step closer lady that my senses will better understand your nature i'm trying to convince the pilgrims to believe in my god because he's my dad you see one's nature eva is it a skill far beyond bugs?
One not without cost.
My sight perceives a bug only through the imprint upon their soul.
You speak of their crest.
That signifies of a bug's essence, an invisible yoke born through a lifetime.
Crest?
Yes, the old weaver term.
A simple word to attempt description of something so refined.
But wait, your own nature, is it?
Lady permit me to look deeper still that may offer clarity sure download me i would like to be on the bugapedia please
evolve the crest of hunter strike enemies repeatedly once focused needle attacks will become deadlier i'm not even using hunter what is this bullshit
incredible your nature is so unlikely immortal bugs your mortal bugs yours is malleable transitory is a marvelous thing you are now where's my long life to behold it's if in your travels you're able to further evolve return to me the wealth power possess I may be able to aid you further thank you Eva and my nature expands as you say I shall return how do i know if my nature expands ladies still my sisters resound you seem so very far beyond the bounds of a bug permit me to gaze upon your nature i may offer clarity downloading people pop you think you think in silk song you have to worry about y2k but it upgraded gain a vesti crest what the is a vesti crest Equip additional tools independent of one's crest.
Is there another one?
Lady, even your travels, you're able.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I got everything.
Oh, so it's...
Oh, I need unlock memory slots for it.
Alright.
Why don't I just free her?
Why am I keeping her cage like this?
Alright.
Why can't I just, like, free her?
here uh oh oh is this like for my compass oh i see so it's like a forever compass lot what's this okay i don't need that actually and then like that oh it's like my my compass lot vesticles yeah but thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
wait what i don't get up there can i see that there's something up there
oh left the bench is a path there's a secret oh there is a secret secret secret tunnel hello
it had a feeling that oh my god what the fuck is that?
Can you roll it down?
Okay, I don't like that.
I like that.
Oh, he's tired.
He's eepy.
Okay, yeah, I can just kill it like that.
There we go.
I don't know what that is, though.
He's a big boy.
Can you think below me?
What's over here?
Oh, this was like...
Oh, I could have...
Oh, that was a shortcut.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I could have just like...
Like, if I don't want to...
If I don't want to do the...
Do the parkour, I just kill him.
He's going to use this for now.
Oh, I forgot.
I'm not a Reaper now.
I have to do diagonal jumps.
I guess they're all like little shortcut.
Like, up is shortcut?
What is down?
Down is nothing.
Guys, I fucked up.
It was nothing.
Thank God I could jump from there.
What's this?
Oh, this is a boss fight.
Oh, it's you.
I killed you before.
Wait, you're a Moss Mother, but I killed you.
How are you still alive?
I killed you.
Whoops.
Let's fuck it.
Let's...
I need to remember that I can only...
I can jump.
Oh, never...
Oh, my God, Moss Father!
Oh, my God!
It's Moss Mother and Moss Father!
Okay, this one...
Sex.
There's too many.
There's too many things on my screen!
Oh, my god, not the...
You guys know when there's too many things on my screen, I can't focus!
I can't focus!
Oh my god.
How...
Look at this.
How are you still alive?!
I feel like I did so much damage.
Moss Mother dead.
Time to kill the dad.
Alright.
There we go.
Moss Mother and Moss Father dead.
I killed a family.
Let's go.
Thank God.
I'll make sure no one will remember them.
Hey, weevlet.
What the fuck is that?
Increases speed of...
I can regenerate silk now?
Let's try.
Let's go.
Thank God.
I hope they're unmarked graves.
No one's gonna remember who they were.
How do I...
Wait, there's something up here.
I hear somebody breathing.
up there oh no it's you it's you all right there you oh my god oh my god not the fucking combo stupid bugs i'll just slowly float over
or just go back
i guess i go back go back to the other and there's a ledge you can climb a ledge Where is the ledge?
Here?
Oh, here!
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say, how do I...
How do I get to that area?
Oh, my god, not you.
It's fine.
I'll take the long way.
Oh, never mind.
There's no...
JK, Jokey, there's no long way.
It's just all way.
What the fuck?
Oh, I had to go the other side anyway.
thing is just a way.
Are you serious?
There you go.
Nice.
Now I have more silk.
Yay!
I'll talk to how many hours is this game?
Well, like, apparently there's an achievement where the speedrunner achievement for this game is to complete a hundred...
It's that 100% this in under 30 hours.
Like, that's the speedrunner achievement.
I was like, 100% in under 30 hours.
Like, what the fuck?
The fact that they call that the speed part.
Yeah.
What is the security camera?
Oh, there's more.
Noink.
Runeheart.
Oh, okay.
It's just money.
I'm sure it's gonna take me a while to complete this.
this i don't think i'm 100 it's gonna take me so long for 100 this low her gaze escape prepare sisters we've hope anew that we might break free this accursed web born of our native foundation
has anyone figured out the true ending yet like what is considered the true ending is that the one after act three i assume act three after act three is the true Oh, hidden wall to there, right?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Whoa!
Oh my god, I got you!
Okay, we spare.
I thought he'd stop.
He's like, got you, got you again!
Okay, why did you go back?
I thought he would stop!
I thought he'd leave afterwards!
I didn't think he'd do it again!
I swear, I've died to it on minions instead of the bosses.
What the fuck?
I was gonna say, why can't I...
I'm just gonna leave.
You ain't tricky.
me.
You're not tricking me.
I know what that place is.
I know exactly what that place is.
I know.
You fool me once.
Shame on you.
I know exactly what that place is.
That's that's not a boss area trust us yeah sure sure
i swear to god if this is a beast fly part two i swear to god
I know what the arena looks like.
I've seen it.
I know exactly what the arena looks like.
Doki, I promise you.
It's just platforming for a mad start.
Bad me if I'm lying.
Fox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll Aka if it's...
Oh, shit.
I'm not looking.
I'll Aka if it's peaceful.
I trust.
It is not there.
I swear to God.
If I go there and it's like Beast Fly in Part 2.
If the Beast Fly shows up.
I swear to God.
I know what the arena looks like.
Okay.
There it comes.
Oh my.
My god, okay, this area, this area sucks.
But, okay.
Okay, might not have been smart to go into this area with, like, already a lack of HP.
Oh, wait, nice.
There's the map chart.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
You guys win this time.
Look, I have trust issues, okay?
Doesn't help.
Don't!
Fuck!
Alright, nice.
What are these little security cameras, anyway?
Like, I feel like they do nothing.
They just look at me.
Like...
What is their purpose?
Like, what is your purpose?
Oh, they're lights?
I don't even need lights.
I thought they were, like, some shitty-ass T-Moo security.
security system.
Alright.
They're always watching me.
Like, you know it's from Timu because like all it does is, wait, where do I go?
I gotta go this way.
All it does, it just pings you and be like, there's this person outside.
your house and that's it that's the security they're just like hey there might be someone outside your house and that's it they don't call anybody they just send you a text message you don't even give you a photo it's just literally a
text okay so where does the witch live I don't remember where she lives there might be
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And that's why I have trust issues.
I keep getting one guide.
Oh, hey, there's a new guy here.
You and the cloak.
Pray tread softly.
I meditate and gather my faith before my pilgrimage begins.
My steps are softened up, madam.
If I disturb you, it was not my intent.
Even your speech far too loud.
I can scarcely hear my thoughts.
Please be away.
Okay.
Down the elevator.
All right.
Upper right.
Yeah?
And then where do I go?
Does she live here?
I like the other guy, but...
Well, he's fucking dead.
It's his own fault, though.
Shouldn't I wish for that beast to die.
That bench in the top right...
Oh!
That's where she lives.
Okay.
And it's his fault.
He's the one...
He made his wish.
Not my fault, the monkey paw curled.
Okay.
This way.
Uh, all the way to the right.
Okay, and then we gotta go right side.
Ooh!
Oh, shit.
You know what?
I got, I need some money anyway.
Okay.
Oh, hey, money.
Yay!
They don't need that.
The pilgrims don't need it.
They're...
They're... to make the pilgrimage.
They gotta...
They gotta let go of all prized possessions and money.
And that... And I'm so generous to take it away from them.
So generous of me.
Oh, there she is.
Hello, I grabbed it.
As promised, Druid, I have your berries.
What is your need for such common fruits?
Common?
No, no.
Special.
Cherish.
Only a druid knows it.
The berry's bright for my wish.
My wish is so dear.
All right, here's your moss berry.
This is them.
The precious promised fruits.
Drop them in.
There they go.
last we can begin.
Alright.
Yay!
What do I get?
Whoa!
Oh, the smell is red like the others, but they're young.
Oh, voices of the woods.
Oh, dance of the queen.
Oh, beat harder.
Let us hear it.
Oh, oh.
Does she make my special goo-goo juice?
Like from honey boo-boo?
The pain.
My mind aches.
White.
The berries.
The nasty fruits.
Oh, the vision.
You.
Wish-promiser.
Wish-granted.
You brought me what I needed and stayed by my side.
Yeah, it just took me like maybe 12 hours.
I got a little sidetracked.
Companion threw my idea.
I could ask for nothing more.
I got his wish Another make a wish kid Satisfied And for a parting A gift An amlet of we druids Or me druid No others I think May ease your sorrow Wish granted May cry for you when no tears are left I get Druid's eyes The amlet weeps a green elixir Oh Okay what should I get Weave light or Oh Increases the speed.
I feel like maybe I should get the druid eye.
I feel like druid eye might be better.
Because I get hit a lot.
Oh, I have a lot of slots here.
Nice.
Alright.
Yeah, I get hit a lot.
I actually stub my toe a lot.
My little toe keeps getting hit.
Yeah, but I feel like for we like to be like good.
long enough to regenerate still when all right time for more wishes what are gonna get track down in a mark sleek feels can be okay uh what the collect silver bells in the tunnels above and below bell where the fuck is that speak to the creak of the halfway home and gray more oh my god there's so many things tip was last seen in lower shellwood okay well do which one should we do which one's most important do you write up pollen okay write up pollen okay we gotta find that where the fuck is that
all right we're we're at our silk song beach episode right now
All right, Silk Song Beach episode.
This is a filler episode.
Wake up.
Smack that booty.
It's time to wake up.
Silk Song Bikini Man went...
Oh, you know someone's gonna make that.
You know, you know someone's gonna make that.
All right, we're...
Okay, it's time.
We gotta figure out.
Where are all the purple flowers?
And you know she's a hack too.
Because like apparently in her journal, she outlived all her, I don't know, boyfriends and girlfriends.
She's like, she's like, oh my god.
It sucks because they all die.
all right she's a cougar yeah jane silk song is actually a cougar all right where are all the where are all of them she hunting yeah
that's why she has the hunter crest out she's always hunting
They're just around.
Wow, thank you guys.
It's really helpful.
Yeah, I want you to try and find all five of them.
I don't even know which one I got.
Did I get this one?
I think I did.
Oh, shit.
I'm pretty sure I got...
All right, guys.
No, no.
I'm gonna tell me where they are now One is left side of a room a room with ability one is a very top of the okay I know I got two
Don't make me pull up a guide Do you know how many I have to get guys?
I have to find four I don't remember Which one I've got but they're next to purple flower petals one left and one right in the middle right one right of middle bench okay one left i assume here right and one right in middle oh my god all right let's find it oh my god kira kira if you can tell me where all the flowers are you'll be unbanished from the backseating council yeah
i will unrevoke i will unrevoke your band from backseating council
you get your membership back you get your backseating membership back
is it here
Around this area.
Okay, it's not here.
Where the fuck is it?
To him, like, here, right?
This guy, though.
Oh, my God.
I forgot about the stick bug.
I forgot how annoying the stick bugs are.
Are there any of them here?
There's not one.
Who told me to go left?
What is it?
Snitch them out right now!
Okay.
Who was it?
Jenny from here?
Oh my god.
I gotta do this stupid parkour shit again.
They're all on the right side.
side of the map.
Okay, thank god I'm on the right side, guys.
Have I done one here yet?
I know I got, I think I got one on this side.
I don't remember.
Oh my god, this guy's so annoying.
Yeah, but I don't know if I've got it already, because I know it's down there to the right.
that over it's over there to the right wait i think i need to parkour that it's to the left oh there it is that's one of them right can i see it i see it okay there's one of the thingies
i remember that i don't have wait what what is that what is this
What is that?
What wish is this?
Oh, it's the lost courier.
It's this lost package.
This Amazon delivery didn't arrive in two days, even though he paid for Prime.
Okay.
This way.
He went back down?
Why did he go back down?
He got lost.
It's GPS wasn't working.
He had no Wi-Fi there.
Wait, oh, I was gonna say, where the fuck is he?
He disappeared.
Okay, down.
Down here.
Oh, my God.
Where is he going?
What?
the fuck how are you why are you doing so many detours
oh my god he's so fucking confused oh i hear him oh i found him there you go i'm here to save you where's my package oh oh there's oh those horrible beastie beasts are gone much and many things are you mighty warrior it was a simple thing small bug i assume you're a tip the courier Frey,
the bell-heart traders seem concerned for your safety and for the cargo you carry.
She said you?
She needs to learn and learn a little patience.
I'm just barely been away.
But still, as lucky as lucky for me you came.
Bro, I saw your pathway.
You went up, down, up down, left, right, then down again.
Like, where are you going?
You went in a circle at one point.
I do not think you know where you're going.
Yeah, he was doing the fucking Konami code path thing.
Well, I must be off now.
Now, grab you grabbing the bell and come after me yourself, and she's not getting her goods.
Alright, goodbye.
And I didn't figure out how I can go back.
No, that motherfucker was not being chased.
Now I have to figure out how to get back, too.
Okay, it's up here.
There you go.
Yeah, I don't go back to Shellwood.
I don't want to go back this way to Shellwood.
Alright, back to the Purple Hearts.
Oh my god, I'm so far from the Purple Hearts.
I was...
That was a long detour.
I had a filler episode within a filler episode.
It started as a beach episode, and now we're on like...
We're now in the jungle.
Okay.
It was like here.
It was like that Iran High School Host Club episode where they were on the beach and then suddenly they were in the jungle.
It's literally that episode.
I think it was like here, right?
Oh, it was here, okay.
Oh, there's the stick bug.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
Not cool.
I'm trying to destroy your home.
That's not cool.
Alright.
Wait, that wasn't it.
What?
Oh, my God.
I thought...
I thought he was a purple flower all along.
Oh, my God.
I just...
I didn't realize not all purples equal flower.
Oh my god, it's on the right side.
Let's see, I remember I got a purple flower here.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god, there it is.
We didn't drop anything.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, we got another one.
No, we got it.
We have three now.
Not all purple is a flower.
Alright, where's the other room?
Is it this one?
This one or which one?
This one?
How do I get there?
Oh, both?
Okay.
Because I don't know which one I already got a purple flower from, so we'll check both rooms.
Oh.
That's fine.
Get him out of here.
Oh my god, can I do that?
I can.
Uh, there you go.
How do I get to this side of the bench?
I assume it's...
What?
Wait, how do I get to that bench?
Oh, the elevator.
Okay.
There you go.
There was a purple at...
Where the fuck is green?
What does that mean?
It's all green.
I don't know if you guys can see, but this is all green, I assume.
Unless I'm colorblind.
What do you mean?
All of this is green.
How can it be...
How can it be any more green?
Oops, I went the wrong way.
I'm gonna get there.
Oh, it's here.
Try to find the other flower.
There should be another flower here.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh, fuck this.
There you go.
Let's kill your home.
All right, two more.
Oh, right side again?
Here?
Oh yeah, there's an area here.
Okay.
I didn't see that area.
Okay, that's not it.
That's just their house.
That's just where they live.
No, I've been here.
I mean, I've been here before?
Oh no, it's another secret.
A long pin?
What's that?
Pierce through...
Oh!
There's another twirl.
Yeah.
Ah, shit.
I gotta kill this orphan.
Cannon, not revenge when you're dead.
Okay, we gotta go.
I'll go this way.
Go to the room above.
Alright, let's take the elevator.
Actually, get the bench.
first.
I don't want to heal.
Alright.
Bench time.
Oh.
Okay.
I should have just parkour.
Never mind.
Elevator time.
It's actually parkour time.
Yeah.
Alright.
Wrong floor.
Oh.
There's a flower.
Here.
Secret.
Nice.
Alright.
One more.
We're missing one more where's the last one guys all right we got this one and we got this one and we got this one wait did we got that one i don't even remember we got these three this one this one or this one or this one or this one all right I'm gonna do one two three one two three which one is it yes yes it's not a yes or no question it's one two okay one two Two,
three, one, one, and five.
Okay, all right, all right, there you go.
We did it, we figured it out.
Wait, we did it, guys.
Hey, freak, you guys, there's no, there's no, it's, the rule is there's, there's only one rule.
It's, oh my, there's only one rule and it's one, it's nearly one, two, or three.
So I am not good with math.
I got confused.
I feel like I got this one, right?
No, I got this one.
I remember.
Yeah, we got this one.
Okay, it's not one.
All right.
It's not this.
One, one, two.
Dragon's cat, cow.
All right.
Two.
Okay.
Guys, there's no three.
I count two!
It's one or two!
Where are you getting three from?
Alright, two.
Okay, is this one?
I get that one already, though?
I don't know.
Oh, it's time to find out.
Apparently they nerfed this boss.
She was so fucking easy.
I was so surprised.
I'm surprised this boss got nerfed.
Okay.
I think we got this one right now.
Oh, no, we didn't, because there's money.
There's money to collect.
Yeah, we didn't get this one.
Oh, my God.
God, I hate these stick bugs.
I hate these flying stick bugs.
I got flying.
It's one of them.
God damn it.
All right.
I'll get our money back.
Accidentally landed on a stick bug.
I got stick bugged into a stick bug.
Alright.
It's this way.
Oh, cruel irony.
Get stick bugged.
Alright.
This should be the...
This has to be the upgrade though.
This guy got run for that.
Alright, nice.
I got hot potato.
Yeah, I did.
I did it.
It was down here, right?
Yeah.
Like, this guy's there just minding his own business and killed me.
His mere existence fucked me up.
No, I think I did this area before.
I'm pretty sure.
Because, like...
No, I definitely did this area.
before I just forgot to
it's up yeah I did it see I did this place already alright so it wasn't here so it's not here yeah alright okay where could the last okay now that we eliminated the all the other flowers I did get is left of the ability pillar here?
Here.
Okay.
I assume that's the ability pillar.
Yeah.
Wait, yep or no?
Someone said no.
Room before.
Here.
Okay, in this room.
Okay, it's in this room.
Okay, is it this?
No.
What could it be?
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
There you go.
I found the flowers.
Alright, who made this wish?
I don't even remember.
Who made this wish?
Okay, it's just...
Oh, shit.
That's not what I want to do.
It's at the...
Okay, I just have to go down.
He did it.
I don't even know who made it.
Who wished for this?
A hut in Shellwood?
Oh, this...
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
Okay, wait.
Actually, I don't know.
There's so many huts.
Okay.
Does she live in one or two?
The squiggly...
Oh, they're both squiggly, though.
This one?
two okay i was gonna say they both have squiggle lands
thank god i waited i was not figuring this out myself oh my god this was where i got the flea i this is where i got the awoo
are you serious you did double damage i'm gonna speak to your manager That was bullshit.
That is bullshit.
Oh my god, I had to go this way.
Get over here.
I need your HP.
Oh my god, this is also why I have trust issues.
You can't trust nothing in this world.
It's just all spikes.
Surprise, it's just all spikes.
Alright.
This way.
Come here.
Come to me.
I need to use you as a platform.
Come on.
Get over here.
Oh my.
Get over.
Oh my god.
Fly down!
Please!
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
I could...
There we go.
I was gonna say I could have actually just parkoured this myself without you using it at that rate okay there you go hello I have your purple the precious hearts give them the time of birth for the right they must lead all right here you go pull apart gathered gathered all all that is needed is given all right Here's your herbal.
Nice.
There you go.
I made your wish come true.
I hope you get cured soon.
The first right.
Right of the polyp.
The first right can begin.
Alright, cool.
Oh my god, what is she doing?
What the fuck is that?
Is she...
Was she eating it?
What the fuck was she doing?
Alright.
What does she give me?
I don't even know what she gave me.
What did she give me?
Oh, nothing yet?
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, I have to wait.
Bug, cloaked by red.
The time a rebirth approaches.
First right is completed.
Prepare for the time of birth.
Take, take the refuge.
use at the right.
Oh, nice.
Applies venom.
Oh!
I have poison now.
Okay.
I was gonna say like, where the fuck is my special gift?
I did your... I did...
You think I did this favor for free?
Alright.
What wish do we complete next, guys?
Oh, shit.
That's like 50% damage?
Nice.
That's good.
That's a good filler.
Alright.
Flint beetles.
Hunter.
March.
Bell's still closer.
It's Loki at Broken.
Flint beetles and silver.
Oh, silver beetles next to me.
Yeah.
I might as well just do the silver beetles.
It's very next to me.
Where am I?
First off.
Before we do anything.
Alright.
And
look, they're just hiding.
They're just like, she's coming.
They're like, shh, she's coming.
Hide under the bench with me, Jerry.
Oh, is there a new wish?
Bro, I don't even have money to buy food.
You think I'm going to donate it to you?
Wait, how much money do I even have?
I can't even, I can't barely afford to sit down.
And you want me to donate to your fucking charity?
Okay, uh...
Porgia was so shaking by his misadventures, I was gonna have the heart to dock his earnings.
I'll as well know.
Take a look at the lovely new goods I have available.
Wow, I love window shopping.
Yay.
Uh...
To heal it, can't say I felt it affects myself, but then I can...
and 80 rosaries?
Is this good?
Oh, makes me yell for...
Oh, I like that.
That's good.
Okay.
It's time.
Alright.
I need to equip poison.
Okay.
Okay, so now my stuff does poison damage.
All right And he knows for a but oh there he is Miss Amy thank you again and again for you and your big big night I miss made it back and grumpy grub go got her goods.
She seemed happy even I won't be traveling out for a while I mean things cool many beasties all about todays are even those pilgrims are now Going angry a bit like old grub grub Miss how remain safe for the moment tip you're smart park to stay within its walls.
Alright, it's time to go farming.
Time to put our farmer hats on, guys.
We growing some tomatoes back in the farm.
Alright, let's go give her a relic.
Is this my collection?
Well, look then.
Look at what I have.
Alright, nice.
Now I got some money.
More.
Bring me more relics in the past.
All right.
We gotta go up.
Okay, up.
How do I...
Okay, we gotta go up for the tunnels.
All right.
We gotta go up.
Up.
Oh, wait.
How do we...
Is this, like, from here?
How about I get there?
This one, right?
I get the bells.
I could donate.
Or...
Dude.
Look at how many bells they have!
Why don't they just sell one of their bells?
Why do I have to do the charity work?
Where is this?
I don't remember.
Okay, is it here?
Is it these guys?
Do they give me...
The silver bells?
Hello.
Oh, oops.
How do I...
No demand for bells in this economy.
Then what's the point?
Oh, they just randomly spawned.
Oh, there it is.
There's one of the bells.
Look, just lead the pilgrims.
Oh, shit.
Just lead the pilgrims into this bellhole.
And then have them seriously died.
No one's going to find their body.
They'll just assume they'll die from the pilgrimage.
Alright.
They'll just assume they die from the pilgrimage because only 10% of them even make it.
Let's push the pilgrims.
Let's just lead them into this area.
We'll just be like it was an accident, you know?
They just somehow wandered into the bell caverns.
Oh no, it's so unfortunate.
Goodbye.
If I, if I, like, come back, do they, like, respawn?
else.
Oh, okay.
They respawn again.
Okay, nice.
That's good to know.
Alright, get these guys out of here.
Let me see if they spawn in here.
Ooh, that was close.
Oh, nice.
I'll take that for oh my god forgot my it's oh hey nice okay nice planned i forgot i can't poke you anymore
oh my god that was an accident i was trying to i accidentally hit the wall Fuck this
Does he fly all the way up?
Oh, he doesn't this fucker
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
I need to go down anyway.
I Need to go down anyway.
It's fine.
I needed to go down.
It's a speed run tactic It was a speed run.
Look at that!
I got my stuff back!
Plan!
Oh, I thought I would fall here.
Okay, fuck this guy, though.
Wait, how many do I need to get?
Three more.
Okay.
It might be one.
Yeah, nice.
Okay, two more.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
Quen!
Alright, one more.
I'll just reset this.
I guess I'll go downstairs?
There might be one.
Oh my god, there's none here.
Is there one here?
Are you serious?
I just need one more.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Just one.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Completed.
Got these guys out of here.
Alright, nice.
And then...
Okay, we're gonna take it to the...
The bell area.
Yeah.
I'll go.
All right.
Take my wish, child.
You sick child.
I hope you get cured.
All right.
I got money.
Okay, now I got money.
I almost have 800.
Do I need to give some money?
I could just buy this, though.
Alright, uh...
What other wish do I have to make?
Alright, what's next?
This guy?
The Flint Beetle?
Oh, whoops, my hands look.
Yeah?
Okay.
We'll tell Flint Beetles.
They have in the marrow.
Alright, we gotta figure out where it is.
Oh, this way.
Okay, uh...
One of them is near the place where I play the carnival games.
That's great.
No.
I go back to my addiction.
It's okay.
I won't relapse.
I swear to God.
It might call me like a green goblin mask, but I won't relapse, guys.
Trust me.
All right, where is it?
Where are...
Uh...
Where are they?
I haven't not gotten up here.
Wait, I should go up here.
What is up here?
Whoops.
I didn't go up there yet.
Uh... Right over here.
What the fuck is up here?
Hello?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, but I killed the widow!
How is he still?
This- oh, never- I thought- I thought I was like- Look, I thought- I didn't realize he was- she was not alive yet!
You know what?
Fuck this, I'm healing.
When?
I got beat, it's so hard.
Oh, nice.
That's, we actually needed that.
Wee.
I thought it was the widow.
I guess the widow didn't do that then.
Okay.
Oh, maybe here?
I haven't locked that area.
Oh, she was only haunting Bellheart.
Oh.
So I thought that was her doing the, all the hauntings.
Oh my god, are you serious?
I was there at the edge.
Oh.
When?
Okay, I need two.
I need your money.
You're not milk making to the citadel.
Don't worry, I'll take you to your god faster.
Technically, I'm doing them all a favor.
They don't have to do the pilgrimage.
In the end.
I'm taking them to their heaven faster.
I'm doing them all a big favor right now.
This room is, like, here.
Get rid of these before I have to do this stupid parkour area.
Here?
No.
Like.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, wait.
This was nothing.
What?
Oh, this just took me to the... That's why it just took me to the shellwood secret wall to the left where where i already got this one i already got it i don't know oh wait this one never mind there was no secret all right where is he oh
go back one room okay oh there it is
i gotta find this okay i should heal actually i should heal and now we find this fucker grab a little bit of farm oh my god that should be illegal making me do this parkour oh my god the sense god that's fine we can find it
we don't need that sense we know where it is i don't know where it is we
All right.
Oh, hey, nice.
Guys, I don't know where it is.
We lost.
Oh, there it is.
I knew where it is.
Okay, this guy's fucking crazy.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was an accident.
Oh, nice.
Easy.
Okay, I'm pretty OP right now.
All right.
Where's the next one, guys?
all right we got we need one more how did i do it i just yell addied us and then they die
left now where now what next up bone bottom what the oh here here yeah Yeah?
Okay.
That's good.
Ow.
Shit.
We'll use that area.
I like my little Navi.
Hey, listen.
But there's like 20 of you guys.
But it's a little worse because there's 20 of you guys.
I gotta figure out which one is the right Navi.
Which one is the Navi that tells the lie and which one's the one that tells the truth.
Only 20?
Yeah, only 20.
And the rest are my bots.
For legal reason, YouTube, that's a joke.
I'm not botting.
You've already changed the algorithm enough.
You already changed the viewer system enough, YouTube.
I think that's proof enough that I'm not botting.
Okay, this way.
All right.
It should be around here.
Oh, there he is.
Whoa.
Are you serious?
Oh, my, that's fine.
I just never stop.
All right, nice.
I got it.
Wish updated.
Um...
All right, nice.
We got that wish.
I still not use my tools, even though I have a an OP OP build for it.
Solid Snake, they give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, listen.
No, don't listen to them.
Listen, you're getting one guy.
Listen.
What that guy's?
Don't keep.
I'm like, I'm listening.
I'm listening.
Okay, um...
Um...
Alright.
Speak.
Do we need to do this crawl bug clearing?
Wait, is that important or nah?
It's pretty quick.
I don't even know what it is.
Speak to the creek of halfway home.
Where the fuck is that?
Like, where?
Rescue, thank you for the super chat thingy.
Thank you.
What is that?
Ada!
Oh, the hotel guy?
I'm just like, where the fuck is that?
Oh, it's in...
It's the end.
Oh!
Get this way.
That's the bar.
Alright.
Time to go.
Let's be o'clock time.
Ow.
God damn stupid flying rats.
I hope the rat...
I hope rats never evolved to have wings.
I mean, that'll be so fucked up.
Oh, hey, is it him?
Yes, go get it.
Oh, sister, I'm still here.
I'm sat...
I'm sat here all bend and bender-aggled, but you look fresh as the day you was hatched.
How you fare so well in these drenched and dangerous lands.
Maybe you got a secret you could share.
None that would offer easy aid, good bug.
Whatever luck or savvy brought you this far, may continue on your journey.
All right.
Winita.
Barkeep, I've seen your quest on the bell times wish wall.
What assistance are you seeking?
Ha, perfect.
You're the able sort.
Now make short work of the task.
The problem is those blasted craws atop here.
My roof is fast, becoming their cozy nest.
Now they groomed so bald, they're starting to attack pilgrims as they pass.
me slay them your sturdy shell seems more than up that task if only we're so simple kill the ones above and more just keep coming it's the warmth in this home you see draws them right i'm looking for a long-term solution a scarecrow i'll build the biggest there's ever been so fearsome i'll keep those crawls away all i need is some rag pelt from the craw bugs themselves hunt him down collect your pelt and bring back me back a heap of the stuff i'll do right okay that's fine that's good we're also next to the pilgrim farm all right we'll just kill these guys anyway i got adidas all right get over here adidas oh that's it there was only two but how much did they need oh my 25 okay we're gonna we're gonna do a home invasion i know where they live
actually actually i'm gonna go here first jk i need their money first all right actually no there's more above me right yeah I'll kill these guys first and then.
God, these guys are so annoying, though.
Okay.
Oh my god, I forgot that they stay in the sky for a while.
All right, I know there's some above me.
I'll go to the source.
All right, there should be more.
No, that's just pilgrim.
Oh, that's fine.
I needed to kill the pilgrims anyway.
I think there's more living.
Where do they live?
They live right here.
This way, there you are.
Oh my god.
I forgot that they do the sleeping thing.
Alright, now they slowly fall.
Very slowly.
Woo!
Oh
Where are they?
Oh my gosh, they fell down
Oh, but wait actually
Let's just do What did I do?
What did I do?
Oh, I wasn't supposed to do that.
Okay Where do they live?
All right This is where I have to go.
This is where they live All right, I'm in your home now
There we go Oh my god, how much HP?
Get back over here get back over here.
Oh my god not like that Oh, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Okay, he gives me four.
Okay, that's good.
All right, I just gotta reset him oh my god i forgot it goes down
does he get reset no he doesn't okay there's the big boy oh my god i forgot about you i forgot this hell get down
you'll get tired i know you do oh okay i mean i'll take that okay oh my god don't worry it'll eventually fall down
but there we go they'll just fall straight down oh um how many okay i'm not even halfway
There has to be more back here.
I know there's more of you.
Oh my god.
I, oh my god.
I didn't think...
I didn't think he was real.
I thought he was a background.
I thought he was part of the background.
Okay, we need more.
We need more birds.
Is there any more birds?
Okay, there's one here.
Get down!
Get down so I can make a fucking scarecrow out of you!
Okay, let's see.
I'll make a scarecrow of...
of your body parts.
Well, I think there's one here, right?
There is.
There you go.
And then there's a big boy, right?
Below me.
There you go, big boy.
There you go.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, I need five more.
Where are the rest?
Are they inside?
Hello?
Where are the other birds?
Oh my god, does it lock again?
Okay, it doesn't.
Okay, thank god.
I was gonna say, if this locks again, I'd be so sad.
Okay, you can't fly that far.
There you go.
Fuen!
Completed.
Omar, this one gave me five.
Where were you when I was farming earlier?
Okay, nice.
When?
We just gotta go back to the bar.
Time to cash in on the money.
Alright, barkeep.
I got your feathers.
Can make your...
Oh, wait, nice.
We actually need that.
Gotta farm some money.
Thank you.
ow thank you
there you go all right 500 i'm almost there i'm halfway i just need 300 more rosaries welcome back traveler how'd you get along with collecting the ragpelt from those mingy craw bugs recycle them they give a five gift and ships they give thank you they're squawking and cooling up there it's starting and wear mightily on my patrons.
All right, here's your ragpelt.
Here's a ragpelt, sir.
I hope the amount is sufficient for your work.
Aye, this should be enough.
Once I find a quiet moment, I'll get straight to building that mighty scarecrow.
Wish me a little luck.
My route should be clear of those pests that were next to you pass by.
Thank you, Klein, Least Traveler.
Nice.
Wish granted.
As payment goes, good use of.
A spare crafting kit.
I've been holding on to it for someone else, but they've been gone long enough that I know they won't be returning.
Thank you, sir.
This is worthy trade for my work.
My tools shall attain an even sharper edge.
Alright, we got the upgrade.
Alright, we did all the wishes!
Is that...
Is that enough?
We finally go do act two now?
Are we strong enough?
Man, pretty sweet.
I got those tools that I definitely am using right now.
Never strong enough.
I say so.
Alright.
Then we should be able to... No.
But you can try.
I can get shield heals in far fields.
What's that?
Where do I go?
Shield heal.
Where the fuck is that?
yeah where's the shield here down left here I don't know what that is but I'll look at it there that's down left okay I'll get that grab the chair okay I'm gonna use the I'll sit down I need a pee I'll be right back
got myself some water too and I read a inked all my London fog.
Also gotta blow my nose.
Alright.
So wait.
Next scene.
Set it in.
Sleep.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Down I'll go.
Wee.
Oh.
Here?
No it's down.
Wee.
Here?
Yeah.
Here.
Up.
Alright.
Okay, I'll get my upgrade.
What's this?
Warding Bell.
Shields the...
Oh!
That's what it...
Oh, wait.
That's really good.
Wait, I should use that.
What is secret?
There's a secret here?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I found it.
it what is that what is this oh I don't get hurt oh it's a pad oh this is where I could use the key oh but I didn't have oh shit I forgot they did two damage oh I can't explore this place yet okay I'll leave Oh my god!
Oh my god, I forgot I forgot that I don't have I don't have my magma charm I forgot what it was like to have fire due to damage I was like what fire hurt
Okay, I gotta get my shit back in there then leave.
I don't want to be here.
Alright, I leave now.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
This place.
This place is a new hell.
Oh my god, I was gonna say, why did it not die?
Why did it not die?
I get extra HP in the ad area.
And they give it a super chat.
They give Thank you.
Okay, let's- alright.
What other stuff do I need to grab?
This is all hell.
I'm just- what if- what if I just- I've already died and this is my hell?
I'm like in the circle of hell right now.
Horde was actually already dead.
Go all the way right.
Keep going, right?
What?
What do you mean?
Yeah, Hornet died in hollowness.
Here?
Yeah, Hornet is actually in a coma.
We're all in a...
She's actually in a coma right now.
Oh!
Here.
Okay, I see.
This is...
This is my Hornet in a coma theory.
It's all happening in her fucking dream right now.
Weeeeee.
I made it.
Nice.
Wee.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Recovered.
Okay, this is where I bought, got the rope shit.
Nice save.
Okay.
Too much wee.
Wee.
Where is it?
Okay, it's all the way to the right.
Ow.
Oh, wait.
Pilgrims.
I got here.
Oh, shit!
I forgot!
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is bad.
This is very bad.
Oh, my God.
But I swear, I cannot die to this guy.
I swear to God.
Don't let me die to him.
Oh my God.
Please, there has to be something I can poke.
Oh, I forgot how to...
I'm so scared.
I'm actually...
Okay.
Oh my God, I'm so scared.
I thought I died there.
I thought I was gonna die.
All right.
What?
All right, what's this?
Oh, it's another security.
Timu security system.
Hello.
Ow.
Oh, I have to make sure I ran all the way, right?
There we go.
I did it.
I figured out this very hard puzzle.
speed anklet.
Anklet of a lever draws upon to increase sprinter speed.
Oh, so I'm just a little faster.
Do I need that, though?
Really?
I don't run a lot, though.
Yeah.
But I don't run a lot.
Oh my god.
Wait, I actually Oh, shit.
I was trying to use my ability.
Oh my god, please.
That's good.
Oh, it depends if I like speed.
Just want to make sure I grab some stuff here.
Because I'm thinking, like, do I actually need that?
Oh, I can't even do this.
I need your money.
I need cash money.
I'm in debt.
Thank you.
I'm in lots of debt right now.
now the the bug mafia is after me all
right uh all right is that everything is there anything else i have to get guys oh god not these guys oh god oh god where am i oh my god just like have less It's magical.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I can't help it.
There's carnival games.
They got me with the carnival games.
I can't help it.
I have to take a loan.
He's the same.
I have so many IOUs.
from the carnival.
Go right inside Bell Beast area.
Why do I have to go to the Bell Beast area?
Isn't that important, though?
I'm just thinking.
I could go to the Citadel now?
Alright, Citadel time.
Um, I should buy some stuff, though.
Wait, actually, I have a memory locket.
I haven't locked it yet.
Might as well.
Alright, oh i could yeah i should refill this maybe and then uh i don't want to try anything here
is there anything cool here all right let's see how fast that'll go
i guess i feel like okay yeah no that is pretty fast but i also feel like i'm gonna run into like 500 enemy i think you know sometimes you sometimes you can go too fast that's a fun fight all right wait actually what do i want to do again i want it to uh oh i want to go back to the battle place to buy stuff have fun wait how much money do i have
580 that's 600 that's 700 i need 100 more okay that you know what that means great more time
all right i feel like that's the easiest way to farm rosaries it's farming time back to the farm we go we need to grab we'll grab 800 just to be safe Look, if they want to prepare for the pilgrimage, I am literally...
I'm literally helping them right now.
Alright.
I'm literally doing them all a favor.
Nice.
Okay, we need to get 700.
We'll get 750 so we can buy... Wait, how much was the...
heal thing was the four heals how much was it yeah 880 okay we'll grab then we'll need to get to 800 we might as well
all right i get rid i have to kill them normally oh no my money
no not my money
it oh what oh my god he parried my adidas adidas
yeah but i want it now i want my whatever the fuck that was that gives me more heels now i don't want to wait no no don't jump in there come on don't jump in there i need your money Oh my god, I swear to God Oh my god, I swear If that bell, like, hit me The bell that slowly went up to me Bro,
that guy had Nike's on He won't let me out of this Oh, he had That bell slowly heading towards me Was pretty fucking scary I should pick those up before Oh It's really easy with a bomb tool.
Do I have a bomb tool?
Oh, you know what?
I should just use the tool.
I should just use the...
Where is it?
Just use the tool and just fuck them up right now.
I already have this, anyway.
There you go.
I have so many shards, it doesn't matter.
Alright.
there we go oh you're still alive there we go all right that should be no wait yeah that should be magical they go 10 get the shoes they can thank you all right we get actually no just just for good luck just for good luck let's kill them one more time there you go all right now we can leave
It gives us a little good luck, you know?
Not for them, but for me.
Because I'm the main character.
There's an ant merchant?
Wait, where is he?
Where is that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's like so many things I haven't spent money on.
They have just too much.
Too many things to spend money on.
Isn't Hunter's March?
Wait, do we have a trolley for Hunter's March?
Oh, it's this area.
Oh, but we never had to go back to the center.
Oh, my God.
We had to go to deep docks.
Oh, from far fields.
As far as feels closer.
Is it closer?
Is deep docks closer?
I'll do deep docks.
Yeah.
Can't believe the ants.
They live.
They live in isolation.
They close the doors for the trolley.
They're an isolationist nation.
They're like, no trolley here.
No outside transportation in my nation.
They refuse to let the outsiders in.
Okay, this way.
Oh shit, I was trying to look at my map.
Are you serious?
I was just looking... Are you... Oh my god!
Just hit everything on me!
You're like the homage!
No technology allowed, an ant nation.
Yeah.
It's like... Oh, here.
We ants don't need no... Oh, this way.
Don't need no trolley.
Wait, I can go back here.
Is he still there?
Wait, it's just them now.
I know, I know, but like, that was the guy that kidnapped me.
He was like...
He was an actual bounty hunter.
He hunted my bounty.
Get out of here.
You can finally wall ride.
There he is.
Wait, he's evil?
Wait, is him again?
guys oh my god oh my they didn't take a chair i thought the merchant was just yeah
wait no i did go to the ad merchant oh no wrong wait did i not unlock wait i think i did unlock a merchant didn't i
Oh, I didn't?
I thought I did.
I don't remember.
No, I meant like from like the first thing, the first part.
Oh, it's at the bench spot.
Oh, oh my god, where am I?
Which is easier.
Give me a sec.
Okay, this way.
I gotta do a rug back.
I didn't realize.
I was like, there's a merchant right here.
Wow, he's pretty big.
for our merchant in my head i was like wow he seems really big for our merchant but all right my bill did i know oh my god i can't oh my god we have to get my money back i just realized how much money i had i just realized guys we have to get our money back i just i just it just hit me
I have so much to lose
Okay, I'm just gonna heal just in case I did not spend anything Okay, we're gonna take this chair
That merchant was still in pain And your pace was cashing in on the chest
Okay, we gotta be careful.
That's good.
Where is it?
This way.
Okay, chair.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, what a shock.
Discover it again so easily.
Like a hapless little hatchling.
It would make a sport of tackling me.
I'd have to redouble my effort at camouflage.
Must return to my observation.
Try not to lay too much a trail when you leave.
Okay, where is he?
Oh, he's up there.
Oh my god.
He was in the other little cubby hole.
Right here.
Wait, no.
Where is he?
He's not here.
Guys.
Left?
Oh my god, it was a hidden.
room okay give let me give me a second i need to get my money i need to get my money first give me a sec we gotta grab our money before we do anything
goodbye okay now i talk to him
all right okay i can't i was gonna say are these i don't remember i was like are these spikes those spice that bounce on them?
My apologies, sir.
Though I can grasp the language of many bugs, your words are unfamiliar even to me.
Those items you have collected, these are the warriors of warriors.
Do you wish to trade?
All right, what does he have?
What the fuck are there any... What the...
Guys, what is a good upgrade?
I don't know what any of these mean.
Mask is really good.
Alright, what does the mask do?
Shields against critical hits, but shatters.
Oh!
Okay.
Plus one.
Oh, okay.
Both are good.
What is this one?
I'll just buy it just because I can.
Well, now I'm pouring out.
Alright.
Arch Sharpebone to take down flight.
Oh my god.
Finally, my anti-air artillery is here.
I have anti-air.
We gotta go to the bench.
Alright, what should I...
Put that here.
That's downward.
And then...
That can...
I'll use this then.
Where are my other crests?
Does my other crest give me more stuff I can do?
2, 2.
Okay, they're all like the same.
Alright, let's try this out.
Okay, let's kill that big guy.
I don't know what he'll give me.
But we'll see.
Okay.
Okay, down!
Okay, we did it!
I don't know what happened!
I don't even know what happened.
Holy shit.
There we go.
Big damage.
Easy.
Oh, it's money.
Nice.
Worth it.
He was guarding his treasure.
Yay!
Home invasion!
Let's go!
Oh my god, let's go!
Yo, I still...
I stole their retirement plan.
This is all the money they plan to use for retiring.
Yay!
I got everything back.
Oh my god, I got my refund.
Their 401k.
Hey, they don't need it anymore.
I blinked and missed the fight.
What are you gonna do with it?
Anyway, the dead cat used that money.
Oh, it was so unfortunate that he died.
How do I upgrade the boomerang?
Well, I can upgrade it?
How?
Yeah, don't have to worry about retiring when they're dead.
Go to Firefields.
Oh, is it much?
Oh, it's Act 3 only.
Okay, nice.
Alright, we got to...
We can find...
The filler episode can finally end.
Now we can get back to the real place.
lot okay we got everything we need all right now go this way
and we go down here i could i could upgrade uh donate to the poor it's like donated it's like donated beverly hills like the la like they literally that town is like rich as fuck and i'm donating to the rich right now like oh my god it's like okay it's i know people don't watch the award shows anymore but apparently apparently they did a thing for the emmys where like it's so fucked up where i was like what so they did a thing at the emmys to counteract people doing a lot yeah i'm donating to the rich like long as speeches so like you know how they used to do like play them off and stuff so for the emmies instead to like incentivize people to like make their speeches short they have a counter where they're like here's the amount of money that we're gonna donate to charity if your speech goes goes longer than the x amount of time required we will take that much we will slowly take the money out of the charity fund like i was like holy that's great so it's like if you're if you and it's
like to like chill a children's hot the charity was to a children's hospital like yeah so so they're like so there's like actual encounter at the bottom right if you if you
yeah it's like they if you if you pass the x amount of seconds they slowly they slowly start taking the money out of the fund like and it's like and they do that in a room full of millionaires and i was because like and the donated amount isn't it's like a hundred grand so like you know they can afford to donate more too so they're doing that in front in front of like a bunch of millionaires sitting in an auditorium that's so fucking crazy like a lot yeah it was a live counter so the when they start going overboard they literally put a live counter of the money being slowly taken away imagine being one of the patients at a children's hospital watching the Emmys when that happened
I was like I was like Like, that's so fucked up.
It's like, see, if you give your speeches long enough, you're literally taking money from children.
There goes your chemo, Jimmy.
Scarlett Johansson decided to thank her mom and dad.
And now that's minus $5,000.
Goodbye to your chemo.
Like, that's so crazy.
Actual extortion.
Alright, let's see.
880?
Oh my gosh.
Alright, I can afford that, though.
I really have...
Wait, what tool does it go on?
It's on blue.
Okay, what do I have?
Oh, wait, I can't...
Oh, that sucks.
Okay.
I guess, ah, fine.
I guess I'll donate to LA.
Fine, LA.
You can take my money.
Fine.
I guess.
Alright, let's go to...
Let's go to Citadel now.
Oh, wait.
Is there a spool?
I didn't even see the spool.
The rich get richer.
Oh, there is a spool.
Oh, I didn't even see that.
Did any more wishes?
No.
Alright, let's just go.
Alright, where do I have to do at the Citadel?
Can I see a free blue slot from the spot?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know if I have...
Um...
I don't know if I've been locked in a memory, though.
Whatever.
We'll figure that out later.
Alright, last six steps.
No, I don't know.
I did all the wishes for the downstairs, the poor people, and the rich, too.
I did all the stuff for the poor and the rich.
All right, now where do we go?
Oh, I'm sorry, little Tim.
Tom, we didn't have enough for your heart surgery.
The millionaire gave him the speech for your recovery.
Talk for 45, 55 seconds instead of 45.
So we were just a couple of bucks short.
Thank you for the super chat, banana.
Thank you, thank you.
Basically, I was like, that's looking crazy.
Holy fuck.
Alright, Grandgate.
He just had to...
He just had to thank God, you know?
Is that crazy to think about?
Oh my God, I forgot about this area.
Oh, I forgot about this.
I thought you were on the board.
I nearly killed.
I literally killed your manager.
Oh, my God.
I don't understand.
How are you still alive?
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
I forgot that one was fake.
All right.
We live in a dystopia.
I missed when...
Remember the day...
Do you remember back then when the orchestra just played you out?
It was really good.
The fact that those were the good old days.
Alright, what do we do here?
And the word for most children.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, bad?
Oh,
I can hit it?
Oh, I didn't realize I can hit it.
Oh, sweet.
Okay.
Whoops, I fucked that up.
Oops.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta hit this one.
Because I messed it up.
I already do it here.
Oh, I have to hit this skill.
What the fuck?
Eh.
Should I figure out?
Oh my.
Hit too small.
Let's see.
How do I...
Did I mess it up?
I think I messed it up.
There we go.
I did it.
Jesus, this is annoying.
Zoom it this way and then...
Alright, there we go.
Holy fuck, that was an annoying one.
Whoa!
More silk though.
More silk.
Got another upgrade.
That was so annoying.
Holy shit.
There's nothing here.
That's it, right?
Wee!
I'm just like real Jane Silksa.
Oh my god, here.
Oh my god, I almost forgot about that place.
Down into the right here.
Where's I go up?
Oh, I don't know where to go now.
I don't know.
Now you go up.
I'm up.
This is not up.
Okay, I already did this area.
Okay.
Man, if only I have a map.
Am I going the right way?
It's so confusing.
Okay, I unlocked this area.
I remember.
There's a bet.
Oh my god.
But is it a free bench or is it pay to sit?
I'll never know.
What's over here?
Hello.
Oh my god.
I thought like something's like this room's gonna crush me.
Alright.
Money.
That just scared me.
I was gonna get crushed.
Yeah, nothing comes for free here.
Is this a bench?
Oh, no, it's a...
It's a map.
Map time!
What do I get?
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my...
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Oh my, oh wow.
Oh wow.
It's like, that's quite big.
Wow, this place, it's pretty big, guys.
Holy shit.
Yeah, that's, it's like it's a citadel or some shit.
I don't know.
Holy shit.
It's like it's some kind of citadel.
Oh, wait, there's more.
Oh, these guys.
Alright.
Chair?
Any chairs here?
Oh, this looks like a boss fight.
Oh, my god!
Okay.
Yeah, I want to heal.
This...
Oh, this looks...
It looks so open.
I don't know.
Oh, that looks like such an open area.
It looks...
It looks very boss-like.
Looks very, very open.
As if something's gonna...
Oh, wait, nice.
Okay.
But thank God it wasn't a boss area.
Oh, never mind.
Hello.
I spoke too soon.
Oh, what's this?
The little spider climbs so high.
Here to stand a quiver at our starling citadel?
No.
Pale child, you return only the mock that I knew nor lad have proven my match.
The sleeping citadel shall be no different.
The spider, dear.
Why must he remain so distressingly optimistic?
The power that waits above you cannot conceive her who would snuff the hope with barely a glance.
Fool, child, you still think me blind to the form of your liege, having come this far?
This lands grandeur, the devotion of its bugs, and the curse that befalls them.
The signs are clear.
Your kingdom is in the thrall of a creature beyond bug, one of that higher caste.
What if it's desired for my silk and my shell?
It shall find I'm quite attached to both.
Marvelous, so that Spider knows something of fathomless beings, and still it hopes to stand against one, a god.
Where do you hide this fathomless strength you claim, Spider?
I've watched your struggle towards us.
Yours was a painful, broken trek.
One needs grace to stand before it's a divine.
Then best you keep watching, child.
I found those who claim this as a god can rarely match the title.
Do you know who my father is?
He's basically a god himself.
And the experience tells me, even gods can fall.
Yeah, and my father is technically dead too.
Alright.
So I know.
Yeah, I know that gods can die.
Because my father is dead.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Nice flex.
All right, nice.
Okay, oh.
All right.
Okay, so...
What the fuck?
Okay, nice.
I can heal here.
When?
Jesus, they're so tanky.
Wait, they're so tanky.
Oh, chairs to the right here?
You guys have so much HP.
Okay, I'll go grab a chair.
What's this?
Okay, well.
I guess no chair.
I guess.
Oh, alright.
No chair for me, I guess.
Oh, what's this?
Yeah, it looked like it could break.
There's a room here.
Hello?
Anything here?
Oh.
What's up here?
Secret.
Oh, nice.
Money.
His final...
Death...
Death wish for me to take his money.
He's like his most prized possession and I'm like, yoink?
Mine now.
Oh, goodbye.
Like, thank God.
Thank God no one will take my money.
I'm like, our money.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I'm just gonna heal actually.
Holy shit, they're so annoying.
That's it!
I'm gonna throw this.
I can't be bothered.
Very annoying bugs.
I'm bringing out the boomerang.
There we go, there's the chair.
Oh my god, a free chair.
That's crazy.
I haven't seen free things in so long.
What's down here?
Hello?
Oh, shit!
What is he doing there?
Okay, this way.
Actual chair.
Don't have to pay for it.
What is over here?
Is his home?
He lives there, Doki.
What's that?
Oh my god, steampunk.
Your steampunk bugged down too?
Where the fuck am I?
Good kid.
Oh shit!
Okay, good.
You know what grinds my gears?
That's a robo bug.
What is he?
What are they doing there?
They can make robots now?
Oh my god, I was not expecting
Yeah, we got we got firemen for silk though There you go Friend friends they work here What are they doing in my way?
Joki, they're just trying to clock in for their nine to five.
Just trying to make some money.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew you were going to come back alive.
Okay, nice.
You don't have wings.
What?
Oh, nice.
I got your silk, though.
Got your silk.
I
thought I was special!
I thought I was special!
What do you mean they can also do that?
What's the point?
If everybody is special, no one is special.
How can I be Jameson?
Silk Song if they can all be Jane Silk Song.
Alright, I guess I go up.
What does this do?
Whoa!
Wait, what?
Oh, I just locked myself out.
God, these guys are so annoying.
I think I don't like these enemies the most so far.
When?
Zeek, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning from Germany, everybody.
Good morning.
Wait, what?
Oh, this gives me silk.
Okay, I don't need silk, though.
Should be fine.
So far.
Yeah.
Oh my god, they do two damage.
Okay, I just don't- I'm scared of.
Okay, that's it.
It's just a silk machine.
I guess that's it.
Dead.
Are you serious?
Alright, I'm just gonna leave.
Anything here?
Oh shit!
Steam.
I got a farmer for silk, actually.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Oh my god!
No, I get better!
Oh my god, I gotta pay.
Actually, I gotta...
I gotta contribute to super capitalism.
I need...
Oh my... Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's not even enough.
It wasn't even enough.
I don't even have enough.
There we go.
I'm paying it over silk.
I can't...
I'd rather pay for silk than die to her.
My ego and reputation was on the line.
Okay.
I ironically had to pay...
I'm part of the problem.
I...
I shall be part of the problem and contribute to it.
What's this?
What's over here?
Hello?
Gung, gung, gung.
Oh, it's a bench.
Look, it was I paid for silk or died to a fucking pilgrim.
Hey, bench time.
Okay.
I skipped a bench and a bell.
Boy, am I you there?
Hell, I see you wasn't wearing that great clang bell just now.
Right when I'm trying to get some sleep.
Oh, hello.
Hamiddi, you dota, you shifty little bell-runger.
You have chosen a curious place to rest, sir.
Do you perhaps know something of the shrine and its companions in the lands below?
No, so you ask.
funny questions as well as cutting bells free, eh?
You certainly ain't a pilgrim.
You're clearly not the choir.
I don't know.
I know exactly what you are.
A bell ringing loud.
A weirdo.
Don't you realize what you've done?
Waking that shrine back up.
Guys, he came from a different time, okay?
Oh, good job.
He came from back then.
He was able to say that, okay.
The bell Has run out far and wide.
The wretched and the lost will have heard his call.
They'll be making a way here now.
Well, what's done is done.
And what's run is run.
Just make sure you come back here soon, you lout.
Oh my god, sir.
You can help me deal with all the...
Whoa!
Guys, he's just a boomer, guys.
He came from a different time.
He was allowed to say that back then.
And desperate scavengers who turn up.
Oh my god, Grandpa.
The shrine awakened and calls out to him.
You see, it's safe here.
Come over.
Ring the ears of every lost pilgrim.
Grubby so and so unlucky enough to have made it to this blast to this blasted citadel with her wits intact.
Well, that's not any bad.
over party that you love I ain't dealing all of my the fresh intake myself time permits sir bug I shall visit again whoa oh my god this guy's a boomer boom okay boomer is there anything up here what's this this is another chair why is there another chair here.
Why is there two chairs here?
Racing, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
What is this?
Oh, it's an elevator.
I was like, why is it so expensive?
Oh!
Oh, it's this old... It's another trolley system.
Wait, there's an elevator up here?
What's up here?
I I've never been up here before.
And their own fast trap.
Oh, yep.
Yeah, that's two sounds right.
No wonder I haven't been up here.
Dude, it's high entry and unsanctioned death.
Ventrica, travel shall henceforth be denied to all of...
Alright.
I was like, that makes sense.
What?
Wait, why can I break...
Oh, there we go.
I was gonna...
sit how come that made a different noise compared to the others we gotta go here then
where am i i'm so lost oh hey silk eater what's that
what the oh do i go up no wait what is there anything else to do oh I can read it?
Oh, it is.
To achieve a cocoon after...
Oh!
So I don't have to, like... I don't have to get a cocoon.
Not yet?
Okay.
It's a restricted area.
Oh, okay.
So I don't have to be here yet.
Alright.
I guess I'll go back.
Go back to the first try.
Alright.
I guess we go left side oh oh he's pretty big what does he do oh shit he does add he does too oh my god you know what fuck you that's right that's right I got boomerang that's right easy I got a stick who will win one time sick or a big boy oh shit there's another big boy okay i was not i didn't think there'd be more than one okay i ran out of i ran out of six guys i didn't think there'd be more big boys there you go nice just use my tools i have so many might as well
Oh, I can't do anything here, so I'll just go this way.
There's another one!
That's it.
I got more sticks.
Yeah, that's lucky, right?
Get over here!
I can add it!
Oh my god.
I can add it up back!
What's better than two big boys?
Three big boys.
Wait, that's...
No.
no I hate that yeah I was gonna say that that looks dangerous I don't like that it's a square guys I was like hmm a square room with two like fucking giant ass bugs guarding it hmm oh hey a chair oh it's not a song clay yay I got my own chair i'm sure it's perfectly fine so we found this place too sister the citadel's grand promise has been strangled away by cursed thread police agree bell here granted us some sanctuary we're among the blessed few granted just a little more living oh there's a wishboy all right this place must provide shelter okay we don't need to do that our settlement sits no more when the worst comes we must bring us pins of the choir bugs those blades okay We can grab that wish.
Best boss in the game upcoming.
Mr. Muflefikens.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No merchant was seen wandering down the coral chambers, but she never made up there.
Her has some foul fortune befallen her.
But she fell the pilgrimage.
So why are we helping her?
She ain't worth...
No, you're not getting my donation.
I ain't getting duped into a cult.
Or...
those like mega churches what are they called the those the the churches that do like the um okay let's just leave the churches where you have to vote you have mail in money for a prayer are you actually just called mega churches yeah the tv ones you know the ones where like if you send us x amount of money on paypal um or like if you venmo us will will just give you a blessing what are those churches called the televen i'm jealous tell televangelist yeah i'm doing that they can give me money for me all right oh wait i've seen fan art them they're like a couple they're like robo couples
i don't trust you
Oh my god, there's two of them.
Oh my, oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't like this.
I already ate this.
Prepare for trouble and make it double.
Oh no, oh no, I don't have a lot of money now.
I don't have a lot of scrap anymore.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Look, I got greedy.
I started, I put, like, lots of my equipment over there.
Look, when it's more than one, I get confused, guys.
You don't understand.
I get so confused when there's more than one.
Does my eyes go, what?
Okay.
Nice.
Whoa, what's that?
Oh my god, they're so romantic.
I'm gonna kill one of them.
Oh my, really?
Oh my god, I didn't realize!
Okay, I actually have to focus so hard.
Because I'm so...
Guys, you don't understand.
When there's too much stuff on my screen, I get so confused that I have to actually focus.
Nice!
I killed one of them so the other has to live the rest of their lives without their...
Let's see it.
It's not fucked up.
Oh shit!
That was my bad.
Yeah, now they're a little faster.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Oh That's my bad Oh shit no I messed up
Please please no
It was so close I fucked up that I don't know how I lived that young Are you serious?
Oh my god because he was slouching oh my god did it again oh no this is so bad
you don't understand he was slouching
oh wait i didn't mess that up i messed that up
there you go
okay nice okay
oh my god to focus so hard you guys don't understand when there's too many things on my screen I can't even think anymore I just gotta play I
okay oh no oh that was close oh Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
Oh.
I hate it.
They're a happy couple.
I hate this.
Disgusting.
How dare they be happy?
Friend.
Are you serious?
Wee.
Okay.
there you go when the mirror makes oh my god it's even faster holy
shit it's so fast it's actually so it's so fast Mike
can't do this yeah I can holy shit I'm My friend!
Oh my god, I'm overclocking.
I'm actually overclocking right now.
I have to overclock.
Friend.
I got overclocked the CPU.
There we go.
Nice.
That's right.
You gotta live the rest of your life.
Knowing.
Knowing that he's dead.
I'll keep you alive.
long life missing your other half that's fucking right wait is he oh what if i never kill you oh this is so sad this is so sad that's right there we go He is sad now.
They got nothing to lose now.
If I could, I'd keep you alive.
Can't believe it.
Imagine being a happy couple.
Pah!
Gotta ruin it.
That's right.
I put the doomed and doomed yowie.
Happy.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My O.
She is a home breaker.
Is that this boss is pretty cool?
Yeah, this boss is good.
I actually, I had to overclock my brain to, like, register how fast they were.
They were so fast.
They're just jealous.
Not jealous.
I don't need that.
I don't need happiness.
I don't need it.
Pilgrim of Fireloom Eternal Your rare chosen Who have ascended to this final threshold Listen to our wish Deliver it That you may rise above And see your pilgrimage end That's jealous I just don't like it When they hold hands And that chosen were How happy they are That they're together Like keep it inside You know Keep it in home Don't give me your PDA.
We can hear the song of the architects at the core of the citadel.
They who sustain our realm, its walls, its floors, and its voice, even as others fall silent.
We'll hear the voice of the keepers within their grand vaults.
They who guard our history, our prayers, and our secrets across the ages.
Yeah, get a room.
Don't show your love to me.
That's our seat.
Dad agrees.
We would hear the melody of the conductors.
High in their gleaming towers.
They bearing the heaviest mantle.
Who would guide our lands.
Ever on to greatness.
This is their room.
Go find a different room.
It's my room now.
He'll get my fire loom eternal.
threefold song that you may rise above and worship before our kingdoms of mine heart i like barged into their room while they were while they're having their own romantic time i was like get a room all right
nice i didn't i did i completed my uphill oh wait i don't have anything don't have a map i never have a map oh it's over here it's now my room oh my god he got closer he got closer he got closer oh my god he's coming over oh bench is under okay we gotta go this way like he jumped all right jump down left from the oh this way oh there's the bench cog war core he's already fed guys he doesn't need food he's just being a little rat he he wants extra food i got built i'm like ikea building my own chair all right i think he won his okay i can't give him his medication though i'll bear back guys it's like he knows he gets treats from when he gets his meds he knows he gets treats he wins
back gave him his meds All right.
I wish I have a map.
Every day I ask that of myself.
When will I ever get a map?
Oh, I got another elevator.
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Yeah, I got that.
Yay.
Streamer luck.
Let's go.
I ask and I receive because I'm a streamer.
I have to go.
Where do I go?
Oh.
All right, guys, we go up, left, or down?
I'll go down, because I'm here anyway.
Party time.
Oh, my God.
There's, like, all these...
What the...
Holy shit, they do so much!
Get out of here.
Yes to all of it.
All right.
I don't like these guys.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I actually don't like this.
bug just this particular bug all right this is the that is the worst enemy so far
i knew they're taking our jobs i knew it you i knew it the ai is taking our jobs remember when we had regular bugs to fight now the a now we have to fight ai I can't believe it.
They even took the NPC's job.
Oh, no.
Not a boss, bro.
Where am I?
Oh, no.
I'm just going to use this.
I don't care.
Ah!
Oh god Oh god Oh fuck this
Oh my god, it doesn't hit him because he's too short
actually too short he's actually he's actually too short this is my cryptidite oh my god that's crazy my short king he was actually too short there was nothing I could do it
back into the room I go I
have to get these guys I cannot deal with these two.
Ah!
I forgot!
I've never learned.
I just...
I just never learned.
I don't know what to tell you.
Oh my god, I hate this.
Oh, friend!
Oh, get out.
Get out of here.
Oh.
There's a!
There's a high ground!
Oh my god.
Why?
Why did they have to use AI?
There we go.
Oh there's more.
Oh no.
No!
I can't believe it.
It's over.
The AI is taking over the world.
I got chat GPT'd.
I knew it.
I knew we should have beat up the...
I knew we should have stopped the Boston Dynamic Fudge.
I knew when they were pushing them they should never have stopped.
I knew.
Never stop pushing those bots.
Why did we fund Boston?
We should have taken Boston's funding.
I never learned.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I don't know why I can't learn.
I don't know why.
I always assume I'm safe.
I don't know why I keep thinking I'll be safe.
I hate this guy.
I hate him so much.
Are you serious?
Oh, oh my god.
Okay, go ahead.
Oh god.
Okay, that's fine.
There's more!
Oh god.
Okay, I looked.
I looked this time.
Okay.
Oh my god, how many?
How many?
Okay.
When?
There you go.
I got it.
Oh god, I did it.
all i got was a fucking lever that was my reward
oh my gosh thank god i actually got more than that thank god it gave me a mask i swear to you guys like that's it i just got a door i they just gave me a door that you get a little door for all your troubles anything else here no oh it's just an emptiness
All right.
I can't- oh, I must need double jump for that.
I assume we can get double jump later.
Oh, open door up left?
How do I get that?
Oh, I missed a switch?
Where's the switch?
I actually missed one, something?
Oh, there it is.
I realized there was a butt in here.
Okay, I got a little shortcut.
Alright.
As we go down.
Oh, shit!
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Let's heal.
Before we rob him.
Okay.
Nice.
I haven't gotten down yet.
Any else down here?
Okay.
We're in the great dining hall.
Alright, there's the...
Oh, hey, what's this?
Hello.
I require my...
I require my servant.
What an awful chat, Clyde.
And we kindly conduct yourself a little more carefully.
And why are you adoring such an awful living red?
By my oath.
Those above must make a sport of sending me the most wretched servant.
Hello?
I am royalty.
I am literally a princess.
Benefract.
I am no servant, sir.
Rather, a guest of sorts.
Invited by the Citadel.
Tell me, is this pile of oil on display your own?
Nothing here is my own, your impregnant young might.
This sacred hall and all the food contained within belong to my most exalted master.
The great gore man, the finest connoisseur, who has ever lived, the one whose taste transcends the ages.
None are left now who venerate them, as they deserve, save for the lonely, loyal, bug who stand before you.
The oil is merely a small savor to whet their appetite for the grand meal to come.
A spectacular far-loom-spanning dish I have been planning for an age.
But last, those above seem to have forsaken my poor master, can never hold together their necessary ingredients.
Blaster indolence.
Still, you terror here, Bug who calls yourself a guest.
If your idol calls me work, put them in the service for exalted great Gormad.
I must remain by my master, so you will need to leave the citadel and gather the ingredients for their meal in my stead.
What is this?
Is this a good wish to get?
To do?
I could check down any ingredient you desire for a price.
The oil you keep here, Maybe it's some use to me.
It's long and hard.
Promise it as a reward, and your master shall have his meal.
Such a squalid bargain ill befits a lone holy servant.
But so be it.
Fetch meat and greeners, and you shall have that pale condiment for yourself.
All right, what is this quest?
Mossberry stew, vintage nectar, couriers, rasher.
Oh my god.
Am I making some fucking...
Mission and the Star meal, like, in this, in this area?
I need double jump first, okay.
All right, let's figure out how to get double jump.
What is this?
I don't even know where I am.
What's this?
Is there anything here?
Is that a secret?
Oh, no.
There's supposed to be a secret here.
Hello?
What is here?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's nice silk eater.
Okay.
I felt like there was a secret here.
I need something before getting the double jump.
What do I need?
I need a needle grab first.
Okay.
All right, now we gotta figure out how to get the needle grab.
Hey.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's time.
It's fucking time.
A fucking course it is.
Okay, it doesn't even matter.
I have fucking wall jump.
What's the point?
Oh wait, that's the point.
Like, I can wall jump.
Okay, I'm just gonna... Wait.
Are you serious?
Stupid bell.
Alright, I got it.
Fuck this.
Hit.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need to kill you for silk.
Alright, uh...
Wait, was there something over here?
Oh yeah, there it is.
What's over here?
There it is.
Oh.
Oh, it's the...
Okay.
It's a start cut.
Alright.
We go this way.
Alright, let's kill it.
Oh, wait.
There's another guy?
Whoa!
What is he doing?
Wait, he's eating myself!
He's eating myself!
Hey, no handouts!
No handouts here!
I earned this some fair and square!
Okay.
Okay, let's find this first.
Alright.
Get him!
Someone called a police!
Wait, I wonder...
Wait, can I...
Oh.
Wait, do I have Pogo?
I can't do that.
If only...
If only I had Pogo, that would look so cool.
What I wanted to be, I was gonna say.
him up into that oh that's what I need I need something for this I can't use that yet so down I'll go oh I can't I guess I'll go right side oh hey who the fuck is that guy wait who are you oh my god I'm gonna heal oh my god he's like fucking it up all right hello who are you hello
garu a fellow warrior brazed this blighted place no you stand before the honor knight god mountain brave companion zaza together zaza and i are bound to scale the citadel and vanquish horror in its hearts.
Oh, and good luck to you, sir, bud.
It is hard to meet another of sound, mild, and a fortune enough to fight back against many haunted husks.
Oh, oh my god.
Never ending.
These natural opponents.
The Citadel seems as, it seems its twisted sorts, and honor decrees we must fight on until we read the heart of its, rend its heart of its decay.
Who are you?
You just came out of nowhere.
Yeah, never, I...
Is he like, oh, he's the guy that helps me for more?
Oh, yeah, I never encountered him.
Leave us to our noble hunt, sister.
The city of Twisted Bug still infect these gilded hauls.
Many are their numbers, but we shall see their life threats severed.
Alright, cool.
Is he like, what's his name?
Um.
The guy you told me the...
What was his name?
The Great and Powerful Bug in Hollow Knight?
him?
He is cool.
The cooler Zote?
Yeah, is he Zote?
Is he the Zote of Silk Song?
Oh my god, I didn't realize my HP.
But is he like the Zote of Silk Song?
No, Zote is cooler.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, that scared me.
Oh, Oh nice, it was just his money!
Okay, I want to grab some silk.
Nice.
When?
Alright.
Yay, money!
Okay, down I'll go.
Whee!
Oh shit!
What was he doing?
Okay, I'll keep going down.
This way.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
There, it's fine.
We're fine.
Yay!
See, I told you we're fine.
Oh, it's a fine pit.
I forgot about that quest.
They're like, remember to grab the fine pit from the guys.
Like, don't worry, I remember.
She did not remember.
Oh, wait.
That's the elevator.
Don't worry, I'll definitely do your quest.
Oh, what's that?
I'm not going there.
What's over here?
Oh, is there anything else?
Oh, wait, there is.
Okay, I just want to farm some silk off of her.
When?
Oh, my God, it's the...
Chad Garmon versus the Virgin Zone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Alan.
over here oh are you serious oh my god oh it's a plea oh all right i did my job
wait where did she come from nice
i refuse to believe their children they're they're dogs they're happy it's like those like parents I'd be like, I want me my child and it's a fucking dog.
What's this?
Oh, it's a pattern?
Bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
Okay.
I'm ready for...
Bum, bum, bum.
Bum.
Oh, it's easy.
No.
Okay.
Um.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Last one.
Yay!
See, guys?
I don't have short attention span.
Look at that.
I can remember.
I'm so fucking smart.
I've got a Cogheart piece.
What the fuck is that?
I'm so good at this game, guys.
Look at that.
I can remember.
See, this is my proof that I don't have ADHD.
Oh, it's him.
It's a BBB guy.
If you can't acknowledge that Horn is 10 out of 10, I know what you are.
Well, well, well.
See what happens to nasty bully bugs when they come after poor old Grindel?
That's a well-deserved end, we reckon.
Citadel was nice and quiet and bursting with goodies.
So what happened, eh?
Why, it's crowding with bullies and buzzy bodies.
The creature that haunts this place is stirring little thief.
The silo's cast now roam the halls.
You'll do well to leave soon if you mean to survive.
Fall again.
When what?
You being merciful?
We're staying here till we're done pilfering.
You should be the one leaving if you're so afraid.
Boy, you've been creeping around this dusty old place for a while, then, sir.
You might be carrying a lot of goodies with you.
Let poor little snitchfile have a quick look.
Hey, hey, hey.
No touching.
Get out.
Here we come.
Oh, man.
Ew, he likes it.
Well, around here and keep your nasty junk to yourself, then.
Hey.
Swiper, no swiping.
Slap.
Hey, swiper, no.
Swiping.
All right, this way.
He's just like me for real for real.
Is there anything here?
No
Might as well just full heal for now just in case.
Oh Okay, no, it's not okay.
It's it's okay.
Thank God.
Okay I thought I was gonna assume it was another bot and every time it's a square I assume the worst I just assume all the square space is is hell Where do I go?
I actually don't know where to go, actually.
Oh my god, stupid belt.
Oh my god, I'm timing it, Ron.
I give up.
You can have it.
I don't care.
I'll go a different way.
You can have it.
Oh my god, of course.
Oh, and then she comes back down.
Okay, I'll just be up this guy.
I don't know where to go.
I'm so lost.
Wait, isn't that...
Oh, it's not here.
Go to that bottom, right?
Oh, I'll go this way.
I already went that area, though.
Where do I go?
Oh, there's bottom, right.
Go to the elevator with the key.
Oh, okay.
I don't remember.
Where is that?
Gone gone.
Gone.
Okay, bottom of this room.
Okay.
Oh my, get away from me.
Yeah?
Is it here?
Oh, I don't have a map.
for this.
Oh, wait, it's here.
Yay!
What's over here, though?
Chair!
Man, thank you for the raise.
Thank you!
Oh, we have a great stream.
Okay, uh...
What do I have?
Oh, my God.
I only have two.
How many pins do I need to get from this wish?
Jesus, 10.
Okay, uh...
Oh, it's fine.
All right, down we go.
We'll have go after that.
Many, thank you for the gift of ship.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, chair.
Oh, not my chair, apparently.
White word.
What's this?
Is this like the doctor's?
An apple of the day keeps the doctor away.
Is this like the hospital?
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god, not the fucking...
Not the bats, these are the bats.
Okay, we got the silk here.
Who's that?
The doctor, is that the doctor?
Hello doctor?
Oh hey, there's a baby!
Oh!
The Coral Commandment.
Oh, it's just a red light.
Oh, there's a dark...
Oh!
Oh my god, what is that?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I thought he was still alive.
What the fuck was that?
He's like...
He's like one with the silk.
Guys, you never go full silk, guys.
This is what happens when you go full silk.
Man, I wish I have a map.
What did I do?
Oh.
Okay, I'm going to sit down.
I know what I did.
I gotta go down again.
I got confused.
Okay, I gotta do this path again.
Wait.
I never seen this one.
Oh, I don't have to.
I don't have the key.
I'm just Metrovanian, you know?
I'm just paying, I'm just making sure it's a real Metrovania.
Ow.
Oh my God, the scene does two damage?
I believe that's bullshit.
Oh my God, I hear the silk man again.
I hear the, I hear him.
He's like, oh, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
I'm not dealing with that.
I
guess I go this way then.
Alright, secret!
Wait, is that silk?
Oh, it is.
I'll grab some silk real quick.
Is that it?
Was the secret just more silk?
Oh, I guess it was just more silk.
It dropped an item?
I didn't see it.
Oh, there was a silky there?
I didn't see the shiny.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
It despawns?
What happened?
Did it fucking die?
How the fuck did it despawn?
It's dead.
It was gonna die anyway!
I was gonna eat it!
That's so dumb.
It fucking, like, rot it into the ground.
Unity, think it was super chat.
Think it was time to go to work.
See y'all in Voss.
Think it was super chat.
Think it was time to go to work.
Yeah, it fucking decayed into the ground, apparently.
What the?
Oh, my God.
I did not mean to do that.
This.
He's gonna keep throwing this at him.
Get fuck up.
That's right.
Get Tani-sticked.
I ain't dealing with that shit.
Oh my god, there's more of you.
I didn't think there was more of you.
Alright, now I'm just gonna...
Getani-sticked.
What?
Okay, I heal.
What's this?
Oh my god, there's another one.
No, it's fine.
You can go.
You can just stay there.
Oh hey, I know.
Inject your ban.
Oh!
Wait, that's good!
Wait, but what can I get rid of?
That lets me heal faster.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can heal faster now, but I have to get rid of- I feel like I can get rid of my extra health.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay, now I'm here.
Secret room above?
How do I get to the secret room?
Oh, too late.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Yes, there's no more secret.
Wee.
What the fuck is that?
Why is she binded?
Is she a bad girl?
Find it for crimes.
What was her crime?
By being a baddie.
Lock her up.
She was a baddie.
Where am I now?
Why is it?
Oh god, it's the...
Okay.
Bench to the left.
What?
Oh, nice.
Bench time.
Okay, uh, we'll get rid of this and put that here.
Oh my gosh, I'm so- there's so many places to go.
I'll go down.
Oh, nice shards.
I'm using my tools more, so that's good.
Wee!
Up I go.
Underworks.
What?
Now I'm here.
Where am I?
Do I have to be here?
Wait, this place?
Down and right.
Okay, give me a sec.
I saw a lot of fire and I don't like it.
Okay, we're gonna have to use this.
I'm scared.
Look, I'm bug, okay?
I'm a bug type.
It'll do two times the damage to me.
Ow, my featsies.
Fire bad.
Fire very bad.
Oh my god.
Oh I made it.
Oh my god!
Okay, I was gonna say.
What is he doing?
Oh my god, not this area.
Oh no, no!
Okay.
It's okay.
Twen!
Yeah, he's a he's a little doesn't really care about his life type of... As long as I go down.
He's happy.
Get this guy out of here.
Oh my god, of course I fucked that up.
Where did I...
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
That's recoverable.
I can recover from this.
Are you safe?
Okay, thank god.
Thank god, thank god I had the magma.
I...
God damn!
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
That's a magma.
I...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
It's no longer okay.
It's no longer...
I leave.
Goodbye.
Get me out of here.
You don't understand.
When I see fire, my head go fire bad.
And it's the bug nature in me.
It makes me go fire bad.
Yeah, I don't have...
I want to say I can farm that one yet.
Okay, I guess not.
Why was he cleaning at the edge?
Why?
It's like a window cleaner just standing at the edge.
Like, what's wrong with you?
What is...
Oh god.
Oh god, get him out!
No!
Leave that.
I didn't even get back there.
I don't...
Okay, it's just like...
The fucking firebomb!
Wait, I must have unlocked a shortcut here.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Oh my get him out of here, get him out of here.
Please get him out of here
Oh my god, please.
We're Because I just need a little bit of silk.
I don't trust myself
There you go It's okay, I can make it I can no
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's not it's okay it's still okay.
It's still okay.
I can make it I can make it guys.
Everything's still okay.
See, it's still okay, guys.
It's still okay.
Dude, can you see that again?
I just want to be sure if it's still okay.
It's still water again, dude.
Guys, it's still okay.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god.
All right, when I'm one HP, I'll eat the silk.
I'm...
It's okay, we can make it.
We can still make it.
Wait, is this way?
Is this way?
Oh my god, I forgot about him.
It's okay.
maybe he'll go into the lava come on come on go oh my god there's literally oh my god there's an invisible wall there oh my god oh my god oh my god it's time it's time i have to eat it i have to eat it okay i i can't i can't i can't risk it i couldn't risk It was...
It was...
It was not...
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I did not trust myself.
The cards were...
It was not the heart of the cards today.
It was not in my favor.
The cards were not in my favor.
Oh my god.
Please sir.
I've been through so much.
Oh, just like I was, I didn't want to deal with it.
Oh, it was all for craft metal.
All for craft metal.
Oh, fuck.
My silk.
My beautiful silk.
Okay.
All right, as long as that lava doesn't hit me, we should be fine.
Lock the fire.
It's not my fault.
It's the fire.
It's the fire, chat.
There's just something about it.
Something about the fire.
I can't think.
It's like a fly when it sees the light.
All I want to do.
All I want to do is just go.
I'm just attracted by the light of the fire.
distant land we who remain have waited long find our strength to yours reclaim the future of our haunted kingdom i'm
like um yeah i'm like a moth attracted to the flame oh i got it i got the needle thread lt and launch silk will be expended strike enemies to replenish silk okay okay nice okay how do i use it yeah i'm just hanging oh oh guess i don't need it
oh okay how the fuck now what do i do i do how do i get over there excuse me oh my god
Oh!
Wee!
I didn't realize!
Oops.
I'm just being a little silly.
I didn't realize, um...
You can use it without the needle.
I thought it was like...
I thought I need to use it for the needle.
Okay, that makes more sense, guys.
Supri- oh my god.
Oh my god, I ran out of silk.
Okay.
I'm just hanging there.
Alright.
What's this for?
What?
Why would there be a hangar here?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like, what?
All right, now let there be...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
Of course.
Okay, of course.
I was like, why would there be a light there?
Surely it's not dangerous, right?
Oh, not you.
Not you.
Okay, that's fine.
God, get you up.
Get out of here.
Okay, I'm just...
I swear to God.
Get out of here.
There you go.
I have to use boomerans on these guys.
Oh!
Got too close.
Oh my god!
Okay, it's fine.
We're in.
I'm just gonna use that.
Fuck that.
You gotta slowly walk up.
This.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I lived.
I live, fools!
That's right!
Oh, it's here.
Wait, what?
Where did you finish exploring?
Hmm.
I don't know.
Do I need to?
Oh, I can go back an item to your left?
Where?
I already did all this stuff.
Oh, here!
all right oh that's where she was talking oh there she is i was like why do i hear master you seen the lone maker left in the citadel are you my enemy the other constructors this place place object aggressively to my presence bug red i am a maker yes enemy no i am an architect only an architect it's a bad automate is not a choice it is our nature directive cage You are a weave type,
yes?
A first child.
Extinct?
Or not?
It does so seem.
That's fine.
You see, a true master.
I bear the linkage of weavers along with other strands.
Equally strange.
Then on your request, Bugret, I direct the road of the demands for farmless first children in our kingdom eternal.
I shall serve.
I shall cook a craft.
Oh, nice.
It's a store.
Um...
Okay, I think that's actually good.
Oh, wait, I should get this, right?
Get this?
Everything is good?
Do I have enough stuff for it?
This, the cobwood wheel?
Okay, technique.
I'll buy the crafting tool kit so I can first.
And then...
I mean, I do have a V.
I keep pressing the wrong one.
I have one beat.
I can grab one more.
All right.
All right, guys.
In my mind, I'm here.
At the height of a corridor means system near complete.
Construct old builds that sound our song.
They mean only to be set, function, and form.
All right.
This one?
It's the scuttlebug.
But up, but up.
Oh.
Um, wheel is nutty?
Alright, we can't afford...
We can't afford two more.
Alright, I'll get the cog wheel.
Oh, that requires the thing.
Alright, wheel is strong.
Okay, we'll try it out.
Should I grab a key?
Actually, I can...
Alright, do I buy a key?
Oh, I need...
Oh, I need five tools to grab it.
Oh, I thought I could.
Hoopsie.
Okay, now I just...
I like that boomerang.
The boomerang's good.
So I'll put this here.
Alright, what do we do?
Where do I go?
Pariah, they give me a super chat they can think.
Yeah, I'm still awake.
I'll fight one more boss before I call it.
That's it, chair.
Um...
Whoa!
Go down left and then left.
Oh my god, it goes zoomings.
It goes room.
Uh, where do we go?
Is it?
Do we go all the way...
Wait.
Here?
Maybe I'll go all the way here.
Go down the hole.
Oh, wait.
There is something.
There's something down the hole.
I didn't see that.
Jesus.
Whoa.
No touchy.
Oh, God, not these guys.
I hate you.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize.
I did not realize there's more.
I did not realize they can.
oh my i did not realize they can come back no no no it
was for you it was all for you um like i was like where did that come from
when holy shit where the fuck did these guys come from
fuck you oh my god these guys are so annoying wait what what's your note oh i can't even get there oh i thought i could
i had to hit that lever on the right to opening
back on the airlift go right here Oh, go back to that bench.
I was like, where do I go?
I'm so confused.
Drop down here.
Oh, here.
Oh, hey.
There's a guy here.
Oh, there we go.
Wait.
I opened that?
Wait, no, I opened this.
I remember.
Yeah, I opened it.
I remember opening it.
Oh, nice.
About a bridge.
Is there anything else here?
Oh, there you go.
Yes, please.
Okay, now I have the elevator.
This doesn't show on my marker, though.
That's the thing.
There must be like...
There must be somewhere where it...
There must be somewhere where it, like, shows the...
Uh...
Oh, I've been here.
Oh, I need a buy from Shakira.
Oh!
That... I've been here before, right?
Yeah, I have.
Okay, we go this way.
Let me out!
Uh...
Okay, first try.
Yeah, because I want I want a pin to know where the elevators are Because I'm confused Is she in the bell area?
Sit down Ahoy Ahoy She's not here
Down and right to the bell way Oh, she's in bell heart Oh, okay, where the fuck is bell heart
Guys, what do you mean by that?
Where the fuck is Bellheart?
Alright, what does he want?
What does this Boomer want?
Oh, I'll see here what your trash behavior has route, Bellringer.
Just as I predicted, this one's peaceful sanctuary is now crawling with all sorts.
With the beginnings of a shabby little settlement all huddled around this old shrine.
These poor bugs are all victims of the city on this insidious attraction.
This place draws them up into its maw, only to consume them utterly.
Inside and out, nothing but a grand gilded lie.
Well, at least these few stragglers can enjoy a moment's safety.
Poor fools.
That's it.
You just want to be racist to me?
He caught me over there so he can be racist to me.
That's crazy.
go
down area okay wait where which area here or here one or two guys one or two all right two okay down we go
it's this way ah god damn it are you what hit me what oh it was oh my i almost went into that
Three.
There was no three, guys.
There was only two.
Oh my god.
I still hit myself.
Oh, I forgot to get... Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
Are you serious?
The random bell out of nowhere?
Oh my god.
She's gonna kill me.
She's actually gonna kill me.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Oh my god, I can do this again.
There you go.
I forgot to get rid of my...
Oh wait, there was silkier.
I should need that.
I had to get rid of the magma thing.
That's fine.
We don't need... We don't care.
Surely I'll find another... I'll find another bench down here.
I believe.
This way.
Down I'll go.
Yeah?
Wait, what is here?
Hello?
Great bugs, ye who weep as your kingdom phase.
Join me upon the stage.
Together we shall inflame the passion of fireloom.
Not allowed to be here, apparently.
Oh, here.
Tram.
Oh, see, I told you.
I told you guys.
I knew there was a tram here.
Knock, knock.
Yay!
My little bug was...
be here now.
Alright.
We need to...
We need to get rid of the magma.
What is I using?
Poison.
There you go.
Okay, I'll...
Nice.
What if I just never get money or spend money ever again?
Damn it.
And we gotta grab some money.
We just need $80.
Alright, that should be enough.
Rest in peace, funny number.
But we gotta progress the game.
Alright, and then we buy the elevator.
I can't believe it.
I'm already poor.
I hate super capitalism.
Oh my god, I forgot.
for her too.
I need more for...
There we go.
How much do I need for Shakira?
Remember when we got 800?
Those were the good old days.
80?
Okay.
I'll just pardon these guys.
These guys give me like...
30.
Alright, here I go.
Ow.
I hit my head.
There we go.
Alright, Dash.
Oh, nice.
Then I got silk.
Nice.
Oh, I keep forgetting to pick these up.
The one mission that keeps telling me to do.
This guy's been, like, waiting there for 20 years.
Like, she'll eventually do my mission.
She'll come back, right?
Alright, she's in Bellheart, right?
Oh, wait.
Not here.
Where is she at?
Alright.
Bellheart.
Ooh, cello.
I haven't seen her so long.
I don't hear her singing, though.
Where's her singing?
Oh!
Ooh, cello!
I hear!
Oh, okay, never mind.
I'm just hearing my voices.
Never mind.
Wait, unless...
Oh, I hear!
Oh, chill-o!
Chikira!
Poshanka, child-wielding kneel.
This heart home is cut free of its curse.
Tell me, was it your blade I brought in saving?
My shock would be great if another hero managed to feed.
I slew a tall creature above the town.
A weaver, I suspect, the one twisted in purpose.
By voice and claw it aided.
Perhaps guided the thread that strung the town.
Weaver?
Those vicious old things.
Pure young we tell the tales.
But I thought them long dead.
Only corpses bound in spires.
This one still lived, though.
If I was a weaver, it was broken in a savage way.
Its own silk was bound, pinned deep within a shell.
A cruel punishment.
Um, I'm not before witnessed.
Even broken, my envy remains.
A Weaver's favotel skill.
To meet one in combat means great challenge and great pride in victory.
Alright.
Where is it?
Wait, she doesn't even have it.
What the fuck?
What?
She doesn't even have it.
You liar?
You're not a.
Shakira, do you not have... Oh, wait.
Oh, there you go.
Never mind.
I think Dr. Yen.
I was like, you liar?
She was like I don't understand what this is So I never made a I never made a pin for it Like pretty useful to me What do you describe sound as hideous Yeah I was going to be a She's like It's unnatural And that's why I don't make pins for it I shall So if it will aid you I shall craft the pin Seek me a moment not long from now The pins will be carved And we may trade Alright
Did she make it yet?
Wait, when does she make it?
Go to the slab and the mountain and she should have it?
Okay, so I have to go to the slab.
I just want to fight one more boss before I...
Oh, rest and come back?
Oh, okay.
Alright, she should have had it.
Guys, which is the closest boss?
I want to fight one more boss Right.
Clock out.
Oh, it'll take a while?
Okay.
I guess...
Wait, she didn't make it!
Oh, it's time...
It's time to go climb a mountain.
I gotta do my own pilgrimage.
And not rest.
I'm resting.
Oh, I need to rest outside the room.
Oh!
Where's the closest bench?
Alright, I'm resting outside.
It's like here.
Bro, fuck off!
Try and find a bench!
Bitch?
Oh my god, it's this way.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Okay, I rested.
Oh shit!
I did not mean to get caged.
Caged for my crimes.
Against humanity.
Alright.
This is my baby Joe.
Alright, this way.
Alright, now.
You should make my thing, right?
Oh hey.
Oh.
No.
My missing brother.
Oh my god, $400?
Let's go this way.
Rich does not need to get richer.
Did she make it?
We must learn from them, child weaving needle.
Peace is a slow poison that would wither even the hardiest bugs.
Oh, yay!
She made it!
Alright.
What is my wishes?
all right what is the close what is the closest boss that's not savage beast fly what no no we are not we are not doing we are not doing beast fly guys we're not i'm not doing beast fly i'm not doing it what is the closest okay not today not guys not today not today guys we have the rest of the week that i have to stream for it i need to make sure my voice is not dead dead by by tomorrow guys we still have the rest of the week
we i still have to stream for wednesday thursday friday and saturday guys like i need i need to make sure i because we know that that fucker's gonna take us a while
white word or climb mountain where the fuck is white word where is that i don't think i've ever an area named Whiteward.
When have we went?
Oh, the doctor.
Oh, I need a second key.
Oh, there it is.
I don't have a second key.
I only have one key.
Oh, the haunted hospital.
Wait, but I don't have a second key.
Oh, my key is in there.
Okay.
Alright, where's the key?
It's a secret key.
Where is it?
Top right here?
Is it here?
Yeah?
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
I was supposed to end stream at 4.
I was supposed to end stream for 4...
I was supposed to stream for 4 hours.
Now it's almost at the six hour mark.
Oh, silk, silly silk sock.
Silly silk sock.
Silk song is so silly.
This way.
Oh my god, Kobe.
Sign this man up for the NFL.
Or NBA.
Whichever one is...
Whichever one pays more for throwing a ball.
Okay, white word is here.
What's this?
Oh, it's one of the missions.
Okay, let's find this missing person.
Where did he go?
Oh shit, okay, we don't care.
Trying to find... I'm trying to find this missing person.
Okay, this way.
Oh my god, they're parkour.
Oh my...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, never mind.
She went down!
She's like, I'm tired now.
Oh my god.
She's like, I'm EP.
Where did she go?
Oh my god, it's that...
No, that's not her.
That's it.
There we go.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we're fine.
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, what a turn.
I fear twas not but myself felt let's see how did you parkour all of that you don't even have wings I bet you're carrying like 600 pounds of equipment it seems this old bug's luck has not yet worn then it was more than luck that saw me to you madam I promise to wish up bugs concerned for your safety parkour granny I urge you to head heed their way now beside the old up and over.
A small settlement has formed there, and the bell we awakened.
Seems to ward away the worst of the citadel's many danger.
A settlement in these long haunted halls.
Are you telling naughty lies, dear one?
Well, I suppose there's not too much danger in going to see in the truth for myself.
Alright, nice.
We got the wandering merchant.
Alright, guys.
I think before next stream, I'm gonna farm some rosaries.
We have so many merchants that we bought nothing from.
because we're broke as hell.
And leave me to gather up my trinkets and bubbles.
If the sentiments of yours truly has bug cell safe, I'll be able to make some lucrative trades.
Blessings and farewell.
Alright.
Before next stream, I am definitely gonna...
I'm definitely gonna farm some rosaries.
This is crazy.
There's too much... I swear I'm missing so many upgrades because I'm just fucking broke.
Wait.
Where is it?
it yet.
It's down here.
Here?
Oh, yeah, the bench.
I'll go get the bench.
I forgot about the bench.
I'll make sure I don't accidentally hit the elevator, though.
Alright, oh yeah, and then...
Yeah, no, I already got everything.
Is it here?
Okay.
Yeah?
Where's the secret key?
Right?
Down then far right.
I hate these guys.
I don't want waste stuff though.
Is there anything secret here?
Fuck this guy.
Now up.
Oh here.
Okay.
I go right over there.
Oh, this is the place where I got...
Okay.
I didn't go this way.
Alright, did I?
I don't remember.
No, I did.
Up again.
How do I go up again?
Oh, here!
Oh!
I was like, guys are stupid.
What do you mean up?
I was the stupid one.
In the end, it was me that stupid.
My guys are so stupid, I was like.
By which way, right or left?
Well, song must be sung.
None may falter.
Infirmity, sickness, death.
All are banished from the citadel.
Oh.
I guess like, if you have like a cold, you're like, well, I guess you die.
How the fuck did that miss?
I mean, I'm just hanging in there.
Oh, there is a key.
Oh, it's this guy.
He went full silk.
Guys, never go full silk, guys.
Remember.
Alright, nice.
Now where do I go?
I got the key.
What the fuck?
Now back to the entrance.
Back to the ornate lock.
Where the fuck is that?
Left at the elevator.
There was another lock?
I don't even remember.
I'm just like, there was another one?
That's near the elevator.
Okay.
Near?
How do I enter the elevator?
Left of the elevator.
Wait, how?
Now what?
Bottom left.
Oh, go back.
Oh, too far.
Wait, what if I...
Wait, I want to...
Apparently I keep telling me to...
Alright.
To go down.
Because there's a secret down here.
Like...
All the way down here.
Oh, there is.
Nice.
Here we got more silk.
Yeah?
Where was this keyhole fit?
Oh, I see.
I see it now.
Yay, zero survival instincts.
Let's go.
Let's go into this deep, dark pit.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, no, this boss sucks.
I can already tell.
Never mind.
No, this boss sucks.
This...
I can already tell.
I can't see.
Wait, not even a boss.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
At least I can see now.
It's little things.
You know what?
Saw, saw, oh!
Oh my god, he's spitting kids!
Twain.
Oh my god, he's spitting kids.
Oh my god.
Saw!
Like, 50% of the fucking...
what the he takes up 50 of the arena okay i was not expecting that i didn't expect him to take up so much of the arena i can't pogo him he is huge
all right okay i get it now
i think okay do i have okay does it go with boss right away okay no i have to fight the little guys first which is fine because this guy can only he doesn't know what to do when you're under him
jesus oh my god that was an accident oh my god that was an accident i'm just gonna i'm gonna threaten this real quick i think the worst part is i can't see i just can't see okay now the big boy
Oh my god, that's fine.
Woo!
Okay.
I'll just use my weapons for now.
Oh my god!
Nice.
Oh my god, you still got me there!
Oh, I cannot...
Are you serious?
Okay, I have to farm silk off of him though.
Oh my god, this guy!
No!
He's so!
Alright, I do have...
Oh my, I keep pressing the other one.
Let's see, I do have... I stored a lot of these.
Alright, craft, craft, craft.
I...
I don't know if I should swap my poke.
Oh, oh, I can't reach that.
get down from here?
Yeah, I can.
I'll just get down from here.
Fuck it.
Actually, no.
I'm making this hard up for myself.
What am I fucking doing?
I should just turn on the elevator, because I can just run straight.
Wee.
Okay.
He just takes up so much of the screen.
I feel like using tools is good against him, but yeah.
I just gotta know when to like, when to use tools and when to not use tools.
I just don't like...
I hate these guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, please fly above me.
Nice!
Alright, there we go.
Oh, wrong one.
oh nice he went back nice okay there
you go there you go i'm just gonna spam tools for now nice
goodbye got your head oh what the fuck okay that's all i'm That was my fault.
That was me being a little stupid.
There you go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, there has to be a phase two.
That can't be the last.
There's no way that's the last I see of him.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, these guys are so annoying.
Twain.
what is he doing oh what is he doing oh what the fuck i
hit my head oh
i accidentally used thread i did not mean to use my thread oh this is bad no i thought i could uh i didn't realize i didn't realize that wasn't jumpable
Yeah, I had a bad timing.
I don't have tax.
I don't think I do.
I have only these.
Oh, I have it?
Wait, what are the tax?
Yeah.
I was like, I'm pretty sure I don't have it.
I didn't see a tax thing.
Yeah, we have no tax.
But I hate these guys.
I hate these guys so much.
I'm just gonna use this.
Fuck that.
Fuck this boss.
I don't care.
I don't care if it was useless.
I hate that guy so much.
There you go.
I timed it correctly.
Let me make sure I don't accidentally...
Play.
Go jump too high.
Oh my god, I accidentally jumped into him.
That was the one thing I'm trying not to do.
Are you serious?
Oh, that's fine.
Oh my god, you fucker!
I messed up.
I messed up with that.
Oh god.
Oh, this is so bad for me.
This is actually so bad for me.
Oh my.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That was... Are you serious?
Okay.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared!
There's too much stuff on my screen.
There's too much stuff on my screen!
My weakness!
No!
My one weakness when there's too much shit on my screen!
I don't know what to do.
It's the boulders.
I don't have poison tax, guys.
I would.
If I could, I would, but I don't.
I think his ass...
I can't help it.
He has a nice ass.
I don't have it.
I don't have the tax, guys.
Booty's so good.
I get hit by it.
Why?
Okay.
I'm just...
I just can't help it.
I just get drawn to the booty.
Oh, wrong one.
Fuck.
I can't remember up is...
I saw.
I can't remember that.
I...
The ass!
The fucking ass, guys.
I can't help it.
Oh
My god, it's always so funny as I can't help it.
I can't why why are you crying?
Okay, I need to pee.
I'll be right back
Back Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay Oh my god, I'm using up all my shards for this one guy I just got to stay away from the booty.
I know it's going to be so hard.
It's going to be so difficult, but I believe in myself.
Just don't slap the ass.
It's literally only taking damage because of this guy's ass.
That's really it.
I have to control myself, guys.
I've got to control myself.
Okay, I'm focusing up.
focus now for real i can't help it it's just right there oh my god here up is the
oh my god that would be so sick if i got all of
okay i parried the out of that there
oh i mistimed it oh my god i mistimed it but that's fine let's go justin
It doesn't... Oh my... Okay, I did another one.
I wasn't expecting the other hit.
Oh my god, it did a second hit!
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I can't help it.
You don't understand.
Oh, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm not okay right now.
The Sidokie stop harassing him.
No, not the...
Oh my
god, he does three.
Try him.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I resisted guys.
I resisted.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, that scared me.
Jesus.
Full focus, full focus, full focus.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh.
There we go.
Phase three, time!
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
Never go full silk.
Okay, that's fine.
There we go.
Phase 3, random bullshit time.
I love random bullshit.
Oh my god, I love random bullshit so much.
Oh my god, please.
Please do more random bullshit only.
Oh, I can't.
I'm sorry.
It was...
It was just...
I was relapsing, okay?
It was just been so long.
I'm sorry, I relapsed.
It was just right there.
I have a problem.
Okay.
I feel like I have to say...
Oh my...
I have to save it for this.
I have to save it for heals.
I don't want to, but I just don't trust...
Yeah, I don't trust myself.
Are you serious?
No!
Please.
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
oh nice oh he did it he fucking did it oh yeah what's
that what did i get what did i get see guys i can restrain myself from the booty look at that i am i am not weak-willed and stop myself.
Oh my god.
Silk Song 2?
Is this Silk Song 2?
See, I just needed an intervention, guys.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I fucked it up.
Oh my god, forgot I have a heart.
I have a second ability.
I forgot about this ability.
It's so long since I used it.
Thank you for the gift of chip.
Thank you.
I forgot it existed.
They're all around us.
Bound forever.
What did I get from that?
What did I get?
What?
What did I give me?
Second silk heart?
Where am I?
What
is this place?
Where is this place?
Oh, I can regen up the two cells.
Oh!
Oh, I see.
Ah, Sid.
No light!
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Oopsie.
I want to see what's up here.
Oh, it's down here.
Oh, it's just nothing.
Alright, it's just nothing.
We just go back.
Oh, it's a...
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
It's...
I'm back here?
I'm back...
I'm here.
Okay, guys.
I need to...
I need to be forgiven, guys.
I need to repent.
Speak confession.
Your sin.
Cleanse.
Barloom never.
Yay!
All my sins have been forgiven.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Where's the free?
The free chair.
See you guys?
Committing murder is okay.
As long as you confess your pure sins.
That's the lesson I learned.
In game.
In-game!
In Silk Song!
For legal reasons, in Silk Song!
Okay, that's it.
Alright, here.
Elevator time.
Elevator!
Alright, we find a chair.
I don't know where the closest chair is.
Oh, first round.
Oh, yeah.
Do we have a merchant now?
all right okay wait i want to talk to the merchant okay no i don't have money for that hello again dear one looks like we both made it up here safe as told and from what a shock to find you're speaking truth about this place a settlement like this in the city of nice and safe but i see so many bugs with mines intact never seen anything like it nor ever Imagine such.
I'm not gonna talk to the racist grandpa!
He's just gonna slur at me!
I want to take lots and lots of roses with me when my strength finally fell.
You have to.
No one do not have to talk to him!
Oh, oh, oh, hey.
What is that?
we want to oh all right you need all of this i don't have enough slots for all of that it's a cat and he's just gonna be racist all right i'm gonna call it here that was fun i said i was gonna be like a semi and long like semi like in between long and short but you know I was like,
I'm going to just stream for four hours, but then six hours happen.
I had fun times.
Silk Song is really fun so far.
I've been enjoying the Silk Song game, so it's been very fun.
And I hope you guys have been enjoying the Silk Song stream, too.
Oh, man, I was going to do a super chat reading later, but I'm tired now.
I stream too long.
I still have, you know, tomorrow I have an afternoon.
stream so i should rest but i'll do super chat reading tomorrow but i hope you guys all had a fun time watching as always i hope oh my gosh he actually he's outside my door he knows he always knows i'm ending he always knows anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you still for me head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys bye you